NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON NOTICES
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBERS OF BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ACOSTA
AGUIAR CURRY ALLEN.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW. BLOOM.
BONTA. BROUGH.
BURKE.
CABALLERO CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES SAYS CHILD.
CHAVEZ CHEN DAVID CHIU. CHOI
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY. COOPER. CUNNINGHAM
DAHLE.
DALY. EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG.
FRAZIER. FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA. GONZALEZ FLETCHER. GRAY.
GRAYSON.
HARPER
HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA.
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON.
LOW. MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA. MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
REYES RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO STEINORTH.
STONE.
THURMOND.
TING VOEPEL. WALDRON WEBER.
WOOD.
MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
UP IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE
STAND FOR TODAY'S IN VOCATION
WAS TO BE OFFERED BY OUR
ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN REVEREND BOB.
OSHITA.
REVEREND.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
IN POST WAR AMERICA OF THE LATE
NINETEEN FORTIES AND FIFTIES.
MY PARENTS TAUGHT THERE FOUR
CHILDREN WITH HOW THEY LIVED
EACH DAY. AND WITH MANY FIRM
CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE MUST ALWAYS BEHAVE WELL.
BOTH MOM AND DAD WERE RAISED IN
JAPAN. AND RETURNED TO THE
COUNTRY OF THEIR BIRTH BEFORE
THE WAR.
SO THEIR FIRST LANGUAGE WITH
JAPANESE.
IF WE WERE ACTING OUT OR
SPEAKING TOO LOUDLY IN PUBLIC AS
CHILDREN OFTEN DO.
THEY WOULD QUIETLY SAY TO US.
COGNITION EYESIGHT.
WITH MOM AND DAD THE MORE GENTLY
THEY SPOKE
THE MORE WEIGHT THEIR WORDS
CARRIED.
AND WHEN WE SPOKE IN JAPANESE WE
KNEW IT WAS A NO NONSENSE
MESSAGE.
ECO GUINEA XIN ASCI LITERALLY
MEANS
CAST THE GOOD SHADOW.
THE IMAGE WAS UNMISTAKABLE.
OUR BEHAVIOR AND OUR ACTIONS
WE CAST A SHADOW THAT WOULD
REFLECT NOT ONLY ON OUR FAMILY.
BUT OUR ENTIRE COMMUNITY OF
JAPANESE AMERICANS.
FROM A VERY YOUNG AGE WE
UNCONSCIOUSLY KNEW THAT WE WERE
AMBASSADORS.
REPRESENTING HOW ALL JAPANESE
MIGHT BE JUDGED BY COUNTRY STILL
CONSIDERING THIS ENEMY ALIENS.
EVERY NEW SAN FANCY SECOND AND
THIRD GENERATION JAPANESE
AMERICAN. GNOSIS TO BE TRUE.
I AM NOW KNOW. THAT WE ARE ALL
AMBASSADORS ON MANY LEVELS.
WHEN WE TRAVEL ABROAD TO
ENCOUNTER FOREIGNERS HERE AT
HOME.
TO THE PEOPLE WE MEET. WE
REPRESENT OUR NATION'S AMAZING
DIVERSITY. AND OUR WAY OF LIFE.
EACH TIME MY WIFE PATTY NOW I
HAVE TRAVELED ABROAD.
WHEREVER WE HAVE ENCOUNTERED THE
KINDNESS OF STRANGERS.
A FEELING REMAINED IN OUR
HEARTS.
THE FEELING WAS THAT.
WE COULD LIVE HERE.
IT IS EASY TO IMAGINE LIVING
WHEREVER THERE IS HUMANKIND.
WE ARE ALL AMBASSADORS IN SO
MANY WAYS.
IT IS AN HONOR TO REPRESENT OUR
FAMILIES BY CITIES OUR STATE AND
OUR NATION.
LET US ALL TRY TO CAST A GOOD
SHADOW. AND BECOME LIVING
EMBODIMENTS OF HUMAN KINDNESS.
NUMBER ONE.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND.
THANK YOU I AM FIGHTING TO
REMAIN STANDING FOR TODAY'S FLAG
SALUTE WHICH WE'VE WHICH WILL BE
DELIVERED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES.
IT YOU THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS.
NATION.
IT IS LAW.
CNN DOT
ROTH.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY MARCH EIGHTH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BE DAHLE MET AT
NINE THIRTY A. M. ON WILL TODD
GLORIA SOMETHING.
SEVENTY EIGHT JUST
RECITING CHIEF CLAIMS TO
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS AT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS OF
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES
FROM THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHT TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS CARILLO HIS AREA. AND
SPEAKER TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR TODAY
THE SPEAKERS GUESTS WILL BE
SEATED IN THE AREA THE ROSTRUM
AND ON THE FLOOR FOR THE STATE
OF THE JUDICIARY ADDRESS DURING
THE JOINT CONVENTION LATER THIS
AFTERNOON.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND. ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE AND
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BERMAN
EGGMAN AGUIAR CURRY WALDRON
MEANS.
ACCORDING TO SPEAK.
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER PURSUANT
TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER A. B..
TWENTY TWO SIXTY SEVEN WOOD FROM
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES TO
BUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
THE ABSENCES ARE DEEMED READ IN
THE NAMES WILL BE RECORDED IN
TODAY'S JOURNAL
.
MISTER BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
YOUR GUESTS INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES IT IS MY PLEASURE TO
INTRODUCE FROM THE TWENTY FOURTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT ELIZABETH
COLLIES EIGHTH GRADERS.
ST ELIZABETH SCHOOL IN PALO ALTO
LET'S GIVE THESE FUTURE POLICY
LEADERS A WARM WELCOME TO THE
STATE CAPITOL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
IT'S MY PLEASURE TODAY TO
INTRODUCE MY YOUNG'S LEGISLATORS
GROUP WITH THE LAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS THEY'VE LEARNED ALL ABOUT
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
TODAY THEY CONDUCTED A COP A.
COUPLE OF MOCK HEARINGS AND GOT
A TOUR OF THE CAPITOL AND AND
THEY ARE FUTURE SO CAN WE PLEASE
GIVE A BIG WELCOME TO MY YOUNG
LEGISLATORS FROM MADERA COUNTY
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYOR SUITS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM SPEAKER I WOULD LIKE
TO WELCOME TO SACRAMENTO TO OUR
STATE CAPITOL.
COUNCILMAN MARK WARNECKE THIS
YEAR'S DELEGATION
FROM LEADERSHIP TORRANCE
LEADERSHIP TORRANCE IS A GREAT
PROGRAM
SPONSOR BUT THE TORTURE CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE. WELCOME TO OUR
STATE CAPITOL
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER YOU
RECOGNIZED.
LET YOU MEADOW SPEAKER REVENUE
MEMBERS I RISE TO WELCOME
STUDENTS FOR MY DISTRICT WE'RE
HERE TO OBSERVE TODAY SESSION.
SEEING THE GALLERY FOR STUDENTS
FROM THE BRADSHAW CHRISTIANS
PUBLIC SPEAKING HONORS CLASS.
THEY'RE HERE TO LEARN HOW TO
UTILIZE OUR LOGICAL REASONING.
PUBLIC SPEAKING SKILLS IN THIS
CHAMBER SO COLLEAGUES BILLION
BEST BEHAVIOR PLEASE.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME WELCOMING
BRADSHAW CHRISTIAN OUR STUDENTS
TO OUR STATE CAPITOL
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME STUDENTS FROM ALEX
ANDERSON VALLEY.
JUNIOR HIGH AND HIGH SCHOOL
SERVICE LEARNING TEAM FROM
BOONVILLE IN MENDOCINO COUNTY
WHO ARE IN THE GALLERY THIS
AFTERNOON. AT THE PLEASURE OF
VISITING WITH THEM LAST YEAR THE
STUDENTS ARE LEARNING HOW TO GET
THINGS DONE. THIS YEAR THERE
PROJECT IS TO RE OPEN PAUL DID
MAKE STATE CAMPGROUND IN TO
BORROW. IF ALL GOES WELL AS THEY
WORK WITH THE PARKS DEPARTMENT
SHOULD BE OPEN BY MEMORIAL DAY.
SO I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
STUDENTS FOR ALL THEIR HARD WORK
ON THIS EXTREMELY WHERE THE
PROJECT. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING WELCOMING THEM WHERE
ARE THEY.
THEY'RE OUT THERE SOMEWHERE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD WHEN THEY
COME IN PLEASE LET US KNOW WHEN
WILL RECOGNIZE.
MEMBERSWERE MOVING TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE. ITEMS ONE
THROUGH FOUR WILL BE CONTINUED.
ITEM FIVE ACR ONE SIXTY THREE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE SIXTY THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER
FLORA AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
COAL RECTAL CANCER AWARENESS
MONTH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLOOR YOU
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
ACR ONE SIXTY THREE. THAT WILL
RECOGNIZE MARK JUST RECTAL
CANCER AWARENESS MONTH.
CORRECT OF CANCER THE SECOND
LEADING.
CAUSE OF CANCER DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA. IS ALSO MOST
TREATABLE CURABLE IN MOST CASES
COMPLETELY PREVENTABLE WHEN
DETECTED EARLY THE SURVIVAL RATE
IS NEARLY NINETY PERCENT.
COLOR TO COMMIT CANCER SCREEN IS
ONE THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
PREVENTIVE MEASURES AND HEALTH
CARE.
AND BY GETTING PROPERLY SCREEN.
WE CAN REDUCE THE RATES OF
DEATH.
BY UP TO TWO HUNDRED AND THREE
THOUSAND DEATHS UP BY THE YEAR
TWENTY THIRTY SO COLLEAGUES I
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO DO
THIS. AND THEN ASKS THE REQUEST
FOR SO BUREAU.
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
FOR POST OFFICE.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS
MEMBERS.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY CO AUTHORS
ON THE MEASURE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR PLEASE SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MOVING TO ITEM SIX HR SEVEN IN
AYE MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION SEVENTY NINE BY
SOME A MEMBER EGGMAN AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO SOCIAL WORK MONTH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT HR
SEVENTY NINE TO BLOOM.
COMMEMORATES MARCH A SOCIAL
WORKER MONTH.
THIS EVERITT RESOLUTION WE'VE
INTRODUCED YEAR AFTER YEAR WE
TALK ABOUT THE HISTORY OF SOCIAL
WORK WHAT WAS PROVIDED FOR.
.
ASIDE IAN AND ALL THE WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE SINCE THE EIGHTEEN
HUNDREDS.
BUT THIS YEAR WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE WORK THAT
SOCIAL WORKERS TO EVERY SINGLE
DAY WHILE WE HAVE A LONG HISTORY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
AND IN THE WORLD FOR THAT
MATTER.
WE DON'T OFTENTIMES TALK ABOUT
AS MUCH AS WE'RE DOING TODAY
MEMBERS WE PASS BILLS EVERY DAY
THAT WE WANT PEOPLE TO GO OUT
NOW ENFORCE. A LOT OF TIMES AS
SOCIAL WORKERS
EVERY DAY IN SCHOOLS SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE OUT THERE PROVIDING
ANXIETY REDUCTION ANXI AND
PROVIDING SUPPORT A WEIRD KIDS
ARE WORRIED ABOUT THINGS LIKE
GUNS AND VIOLENCE IN THEIR HOMES
AND VIOLENCE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. ITS SOCIAL WORKERS
ON THE FRONT LINES TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THOSE KIDS ARE READY
TO BE ABLE TO LEARN. WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT HOSPITALS MEMBERS
THEIR SOCIAL WORKERS IN
HOSPITALS HELPING FAMILIES COPE
WITH DIFFICULT DIAGNOSES.
WALKING BUT WITH THEIR HAND AS
THEY WALK TO THAT BILLS FINAL
PASSAGEWAYS. GREETING YOUNG
CHILDREN AS THEY COME IN AND ARE
ARE FRIGHTENED BY THE VIOLENCE
OR THE THE TRAUMA THAT THEY HAVE
ENCOUNTERED.
I DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TIMES
WORKING HOSPITAL EMERGENCY ROOMS
AND AND ONE TRAUMA VICTIMS COME
AND THEY HAVE A WHOLE FAMILY
THAT'S OFTENTIMES SITTING IN THE
MERGER ZERO WITH THEM THAT'S
OFTEN A SOCIAL WORKER WHO WAS
OUT PROVIDES AT SUPPORT. IN
THOSE EARLY MOMENTS WHEN.
PEOPLE HEAR BAD NEWS.
WE HAVE SOCIAL WORKERS OUT THE
STREETS RIGHT NOW WE TALK A LOT
ABOUT HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING
AND AND THAT THE WORK THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE. AND IT SOCIAL
WORKERS MEMBERS OUT THERE HAND
TO HAND ON THE STREETS AS WELL
AS TRYING TO ADVOCATE FOR MORE
HOUSING.
WE PASS THINGS ABOUT CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE AND THE ELDERLY AND
IT'S ALSO AGAIN SOCIAL WORKERS
PROVIDING THOSE SERVICES. TO
MAKE SURE OUR SOCIETY IS ABLE TO
MEET OUR OBLIGATIONS TO HUMANITY
THROUGH THE DIRECT WORK THAT WE
OFTEN DO. I AND YET AS ALL THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING EVERY
SINGLE DAY THEY TOOK TIME OUT
LAST WEEK TO COME UP IN THE
LOBBY YOU ON BILLS THAT THEY
THINK ARE IMPORTANT PROPOSED
THAT THEY THINK ARE IMPORTANT TO
BE ABLE TO ADD TO THE QUALITY OF
LIFE FOR CALIFORNIANS.
SO AS WE REAP REFLECT ON THE ON
THE GRAND HISTORY OF SOCIAL WORK
LET'S ALSO NOT FORGET THAT
THEY'RE OUT THERE EVERY SINGLE
DAY. TRYING TO IMPLEMENT TO THE
BEST OF THEIR ABILITY THE LAWS
THAT WE PASS TO PROVIDE A
SUPPORT THAT PEOPLE NEED US SO
THAT WE GOT ALWAYS REALLY BE
THAT THAT KIND PLACE I THINK
THAT WE ALL STRIVE TO BE WHERE
CHILDREN. ADULTS OUR SENIORS ARE
DIFFERENTLY ABLE ARE ALSO ABLE
TO LIVE WITH AS MUCH DIGNITY AS
POSSIBLE AYE US FOR THE FIRST
RULE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
SINGAPORE THE DISCUSSION THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE FOR.
MEMBERS THIS RULES FOR COAL
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS IS RULES CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLES FOR CO AUTHORS.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY FIVE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE ON THE MEASURE
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR. PLEASE
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM SEVEN ACR ONE
FORTY EIGHT MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FORTY EIGHT BY SOME
REMEMBERED AS ARIANNA RELATIVE
TO THE PERSIAN NEW YEAR.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR FULL
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN
THIS AREA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES.
IT'S AN HONOR TO PRESENT ACR
ONE FORTY EIGHT TO COMMEMORATE.
MARCH TWENTY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AS THE BEGINNING OF NO
RUSE
THE PERSIAN NEW YEAR.
NO CELEBRATES THE RENEWAL OF
SPRING USHERS AND ALONG WITH THE
UNIVERSAL MESSAGES OF
BROTHERHOOD FRIENDSHIP AND CO
EXISTENCE FOR ALL OF HUMANITY.
THE DAY'S FOCUS ON RE
CONCILIATION AND NEIGHBORLINESS.
TRIBUTE TO CULTURAL DIVERSITY
AND COOPERATION AMONG PEOPLE
FROM DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES AND
BACKGROUNDS.
THIS MAY BE WHY NOR RUSE IS NOT
ONLY CELEBRATED BY MILLIONS
LIVING IN IRAN. AND IN THE U. S.
BUT BY COUNTLESS OTHERS
THROUGHOUT ASIA. NOSES MESSAGE
OF CELEBRATION AND HOPE IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT AT A TIME
WHEN WE'RE FACING CONTINUED ANTI
IMMIGRANT SENTIMENT.
CALIFORNIANS OF IRANIAN HERITAGE
HAVE BEEN LEADERS IN THEIR
SPHERES OF INFLUENCE AND
INTEGRAL TO THE FABRIC OF OUR
THRIVING STATE. FOR SEVERAL
GENERATIONS.
COMMEMORATING NOR RUSE ALLOWS US
TO BREAK DOWN SOME OF THE WALLS
OTHERS WOULD TRY TO PUT. IN
PLACE OF REVEALING OUR COMMON
HUMANITY.
TRUTH AND FREEDOM ALWAYS HAVE A
WAY OF REVEALING THEMSELVES AND
PEACE SHOULD ALWAYS BE SOMETHING
WE STRIVE FOR.
EVEN THROUGH THE SMALLEST
GESTURES.
WITH THAT COLLEAGUES JUST WANNA
TELL YOU ON A PERSONAL BASIS.
OUR I WOULDN'T OF BEEN STANDING
HERE BEFORE ALL OF YOU. HAD THE
OUR CURRENT PRESIDENT.
BEEN PRESIDENT IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE WHEN MY MOTHER AND I.
I HAD TO FLEE IRAN AND COME TO
THE UNITED STATES.
UNDER THE CURRENT.
ORDERS.
I WOULD HAVE BEEN SENT BACK. AS
SOON AS MY FEET TOUCH THE GROUND
AT LAX AIRPORT.
SO.
JUST WANTED TO. EXPLAIN TO WHAT
EXTENT THIS HAS AN IMPACT.
AND WHAT CONTRIBUTIONS WE MIGHT
BE MISSING
GIVEN SOME OF THE HARSH TONE.
THAT HAS BEEN PUT INTO PLACE.
WITH THAT I SAY THANK YOU TO ALL
OF YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AS CHAIR OF THE JEWISH
CAUCUS I JOIN OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY. AND
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE FORTY
EIGHT EIGHT ZERO ONE FORTY EIGHT
NARROWS MEANS NEW DAY IN FARSI
SIMILAR TO RUSSIA SHAUNA THE
JEWISH NEW YEAR IS IT TIME FOR A
FLAT. AND START A NEW.
IN THE WEEKS LEADING UP TO NOW
IS FAMILY SPEND TIME CLEANING
AND FIXING THEIR HOMES THE
TRADITION IS CALLED. CONNIE TO
CONNIE.
OR SHAKING THE HOUSE
A TRADITION IS NOT ONLY ABOUT
TIED IN THE HOUSE AS IT ALSO
REPRESENTS A SPIRITUAL CLEANING.
IT STEMS FROM THE ZOROASTRIAN
IDEA OF PURIFYING WITH
CLEANLINESS AS A MEASURE FOR
KEEPING EVIL AWAY FROM THE
KINGDOM OF GOOD. MANY CULTURES
AROUND THE WORLD INCLUDING THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY DURING PASSOVER
PARTICIPATE IN SPRING CLEANING
WE CAN LEARN FROM CUSTOMS LIKE
NARUSE. DUSTING AND VACUUMING
AND ORGANIZING ARE SYMBOLIC OF
ELIMINATING NEGATIVITY FROM OUR
LIVES WE MUST OVERCOME THIS
YEAR'S OBSTACLES IN BRING
HAPPINESS INTO OUR HOMES AS WE
ENTER INTO A NEW SEASON. I URGE
EVERYONE TO LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
DIFFERENT CUSTOMS THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR GREAT.
STATE AND COUNTRY I WISH
EVERYONE WHO CELEBRATES NARUSE
HAPPY NEW YEAR I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER JONES SAWYER
YOU RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I RISE
IN SUPPORT ACR ONE FOUR EIGHT.
THE RUSE IS AN ANCESTRAL BOMB
FESTIVITY MARKING THE FIRST DAY
OF SPRING AND RENEWAL NATURE.
THE DAY ALSO FOCUS ON
RECONCILIATION AND
NEIGHBORLINESS
CONTRIBUTING TO CULTURAL
DIVERSITY AND FRIENDSHIP AMONG
PEOPLE IN DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES.
IT WAS A BRICK COOK PROCLAIM AN
OFFICIAL UN OBSERVANCE BECAUSE
IT PROMOTES PEACE
S. SOLIDARITY. FAR TOO OFTEN
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES TEND TO
STAY IN THE SHADOW OF THE STIGMA
CAST UPON THEM FOR THIS REASON
IS IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
RUSE AND ACKNOWLEDGE THE RICH
CULTURE OF NOT JUST IRANIAN.
AMERICAN COMMUNITY BALL
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA
NO ROOTS IS A CELEBRATION OF
PEACE AND GOODWILL. FOR THE
PEOPLE CELEBRATING A RUSE IT HAS
IT IS A TIME TO APPRECIATE THEIR
HERITAGE HOWEVER NO ROOTS GIVES
EVERYONE AN OPPORTUNIST
CELEBRATE THE HOPE. OF A NEW
YEAR FILLED WITH HEALTH.
PRICE
PROSPERITY LOVE JOY AND SUCCESS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER KNOWS
AREA ARE YOU REQUESTING CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
I M. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEN OUR FURTHER
DISCUSSION ABOUT A QUICKLY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE FOR COFFEE.
MEMBERS THIS RULES FOR COAL
AUTHORS.
THIS ROLL CALL IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
RULE.
THERE ARE SIXTY SIX CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTIONS.
FROM US TO MELONES DESK.
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM SPEAKER.
I WE'RE JOINED TODAY BY AN
IRANIAN AMERICAN DELEGATION
COMPOSED OF PROFESSIONALS
COMMUNITY LEADERS AND ARTISTS TO
WITNESS OUR FIFTH KNOWS
RECOGNITION. IN AND OUR CHAMBERS
OF.
WITH ME STANDING ARE MISTER BE
JAN A START TP. WHO IS?
A PROBABLY A VERY IMPORTANT
FIGURE FOR MOST OF MY NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COLLEAGUES HE IS THE
CALTRANS DISTRICT DIRECTOR
NUMBER FOUR AREA FOR SERVING
SAID NO MY NAPA SOLANO MARINE
SAN FRANCISCO CONTRA COSTA HOW
ALAMEDA SEND MATEO AND SANTA
CLARA. TO WELCOME.
MISTER YARD. MISH KATHY IS THE
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY RELATIONS
FOR COLDWELL BANKER IN BEVERLY
HILLS.
DOCTOR AMIR A MONTH HOW MEATY IS
AN INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
EXPERT IN GLOBAL TERRORISM AND
FORMER U. S. SPECIAL AGENT IN
CHARGE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
DRUG ENFORCEMENT ADMINISTRATION.
MISS MAGGIE SO HONEY IS A LOCAL
BUSINESS OWNER AND A DYNAMITE OF
AN INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS PAIRED UP
WITH ME EVERY YEAR AND AS HELP
PUT TOGETHER AT THIS EVENT WITH
US FAQ MAGGIE.
A DOCTOR DAVID RIGHT HE ME AND
IS PART OF THE INTERGOVERNMENTAL
AND LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS TEAMS.
FOR THE LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT
OF WATER AND POWER AND SOMEONE
THAT'S A GO TO FIGURE AMONGST
ALL THE COUNCIL AND LOCAL.
ASSEMBLY SENATE OFFICES.
DR CARMEL MELAMED IS AN AWARD
WINNING INTERNATIONALLY
PUBLISHED JOURNALISTS AND
ATTORNEY BASED IN LOS ANGELES.
AND THE LAST BUT NOT LEAST HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE.
MR CAMERON.
COVER RONNIE.
HE IS A RENOWNED ARCHITECT AND
ARTIST LIVING IN SANTA MONICA HE
HAS RECEIVED MANY INTERNATIONAL
AND NATIONAL AWARDS
INCLUDING ONE FROM THE US
CONGRESS. HIS ART HAS BEEN KNOWN
TO HAVE BEEN THERE TO TO BE
THERAPEUTIC.
AND HAS BEEN SHOWCASED IN MANY
COUNTRIES INCLUDING THE VATICAN.
MISTER BLOOM.
I WILL BE ASKING HIM TO JOIN
WITH ME AS WE PRESENT MISTER
HAVE IRONY WITH A RESOLUTION AND
BEFORE I PUT THE MIKE DOWN
COLLEAGUES. LIKE TO INVITE ALL
OF YOU TO.
CELEBRATE NOR RUSE.
RIGHT AFTER. THE END OF OUR
SESSION AT THE GOVERNOR'S
COUNCIL.
THANK YOU AGAIN VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR RECOGNITION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS INTO.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ALSO IN
CELEBRATION OF NOWRUZ WE HAVE
SEVERAL.
FAMILIES JOINING US IN THE
GALLERY WHO ARE FROM THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO AREA FROM MY DISTRICT
AND THE DISTRICT OF MY COLLEAGUE
HERE FROM. OUR PLASTER COUNTY I
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THERE'S A HIGH
DONNIE MARY IN THE BOSTON FAMILY
UP IN THE GALLERY THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AND WILL TRY
THIS THE SECOND TIME HERE LIKE
TO INTRODUCE THE STUDENTS
VISITING FROM ANDERSON VALLEY
JUNIOR HIGH AND HIGH SCHOOL YOU
UP THERE SOMEWHERE RIGHT.
GOOD GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THE SUITS ARE HERE.
.
LEARN HOW TO GET THINGS DONE
THEY'RE WORKING ON OPENING TRY
TO REOPEN THE PAUL DID MAKE
STATE CAMPGROUND IN NOW BEEN
MENDOCINO COUNTY. AND I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT THEIR WHERE THE
PROJECT I THANK THEM FOR BEING
HERE TO VISIT US TODAY AT THE
CAPITOL THANKS SO MUCH.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA YOUR RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GUESTS ENTERED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THIS
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL VALLEY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION
LOCATED UP HERE IN THE GALLERY
TO OUR LEFT.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY EDC IS A
REGIONAL MARKETING GROUP WHOSE
MISSION IS TO PROMOTE JOB
CREATION IN THE VALLEY MOUNTAIN
AND DESERT COMMUNITIES.
LOCATED IN FRESNO KERN KINGS
MADERA MERCED SAN JOAQUIN
STANISLAUS AND TULARE COUNTIES.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY EDC WAS BORN
IN THE LATE NINETEEN EIGHTIES BY
THE PROFESSIONAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ORGANIZATIONS.
SERVING THE EIGHT COUNTIES AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
THEY WORKED IN COLLABORATION IN
ORDER TO MARKET CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA AS A HIGHLY DESIRABLE
LOCATION.
FOR COMPANIES LOOKING TO EXPAND
INTO AREAS OF A RAPIDLY GROWING
AND RICH IN RESOURCES.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING LEE
AND THE BIRDS THE PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE PRESIDENT COUNTY
SEE. ALONG WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
FROM THE SEVEN OTHER EDCS FROM
THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
THANK YOU WE'RE MOVING BACK TO
FILE ORDER.
MOVING TO ITEM EIGHT HR EIGHTY
THREE MADAM CLERK
READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION
THREE BY SAM LAMBERT COPIER
RELATIVE TO.
AND DRUG ABUSE AWARENESS MONTH.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COVER EUROPE.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
HR EIGHTY THREE WHICH RECOGNIZES
MARCH NINETEEN.
HER CHIN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WRONG
DECADE.
AS PRESCRIPTION DRUG ABUSE
AWARENESS MONTH I WAS TRYING TO
SEE IF ANYBODY WAS AWAKE I GUESS
OR.
DRUG OVERDOSES ARE THE LEASE THE
LEADING CAUSE OF ACCIDENTAL
DEATH IN THE UNITED STATES
OPIOID ADDICTION IS DRIVING THIS
EPIDEMIC AND RECENT DATA SUGGEST
THAT OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
OVERDOSE DEATHS.
RELATED PRESCRIPTION PAIN
RELIEVERS IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN.
NOT MANY PEOPLE THINK OF HOW
EASILY PRESCRIPTION DRUG ABUSE
CAN SPREAD THROUGHOUT OF
HOUSEHOLD NOT JUST AFFECTING THE
PERSON WHO IS PRESCRIBED THE
MEDICATION.
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN AN ALARMING
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
OVERDOSES BY CHILDREN AND TEENS
EITHER FROM CURIOUS
EXPERIMENTATION OR ACCIDENTAL
INGESTION AND THE OBTAIN THESE
PRESCRIPTION PILLS FROM THEIR
OWN HOMES.
THE NATIONAL CENTER ON ADDICTION
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE HAS TIME
THAT FOUND THAT NINETY PERCENT
OF THE PEOPLE WITH SUBSTANCE
ABUSE USE DISORDER BEGAN USING
STE SUBSTANCES BEFORE THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN.
IN ADDITION THE TEEN ABUSE THE
NUMBER OF EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS
FOR ACCIDENTAL POISONINGS AMONG
YOUNG CHILDREN HAS TRIPLED SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN.
AND FEWER THAT CDC HAS ADVISED
THAT FEWER THAN THREE PERCENT OF
HOUSEHOLDS NATIONWIDE LOCK UP
THE PRESCRIPTION MEDICATION.
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE TO PREVENT
CHILDREN AND TEENS FROM BECOMING
FUTURE ABUSERS OF PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS AND IT ALL BEGINS WITH
EDUCATION AND THAT'S WHY MARCH
OF THIS MONTH. HAS BEEN
DESIGNATED AS PRESCRIPTION DRUG
ABUSE AWARENESS MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA GIVING THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GET INFORMATION ABOUT
PRESCRIPTION DRUG ABUSE BY
HOLDING COMMUNITY EVENTS IN AN
EFFORT TO CURB THIS EPIDEMIC.
THIS IS A VITAL STEP WE CAN ALL
TAKE IN OUR COMMUNITIES TO
ENCOURAGE THOSE. WHO NEEDED TO
SEEK HELP? AND PREVENT FUTURE
ADDICTIONS BY TAKING THE PER.
PRECAUTIONS TO LOCK UP OPIOIDS
SO MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
COMMEMORATING HR EIGHTY THREE S.
PRESCRIPTION DRUG ABUSE
AWARENESS MONTH AND ENCOURAGE
ALL CITIZENS TO ACTIVELY
PARTICIPATE. IN DRUG ABUSE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS AND
ACTIVITIES THANK YOU AND I'D
LIKE TO ASK MADAM SPEAKER THAT
THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR COST
THERE'S.
THANK YOU SINGAPORE THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT A QUICK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE FOR
THIS ROLES FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN EURO IS
ASKING FOR COAL AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THEIR SIXTY FIVE CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'LL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR PLEASE SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MOVING TO ITEM NINE HR EIGHTY
FOR THE CLERK WILL PLEASE READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION EIGHTY FOUR BY
SOMEONE MEMBER COPIER ANOTHER'S
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE DAY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CAVALIERI
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MEDI SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. EACH ARE EIGHTY FOUR
HONORS CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURE
DAY A DAY OF CELEBRATION
COMMEMORATING AGRICULTURE'S
VITAL ROLE IN KEEPING
CALIFORNIANS NURSED.
AND CONTRIBUTING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY.
THE THEME OF THIS YEAR'S
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE DAY IS
CLIMATE SMART. CALIFORNIA GROWN.
ON TUESDAY TOMORROW MARCH
TWENTIETH AGRICULTURALIST FROM
AROUND CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE
DISPLAYS ON THE WEST LAWN OF THE
CAPITOL.
TO SHOW OFF THE INNOVATIVE WAYS
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE IS
GETTING LOCAL FARM FRESH FOOD TO
CALIFORNIA TABLES.
TODAY'S AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY
OFFERS MANY CAREER OPPORTUNITIES
FROM ON FARM CULTIVATION TO FOOD
SCIENCE AND ENGINEERING CLIMATE
T.. CLIMATE CHANGE ADOPTION ON
FARMS USE OF ROBOTICS TO
INCREASE YIELDS AND WATER
EFFICIENCY IN IRRIGATION
IRRIGATION TECHNIQUES.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN THE LARGEST
AG STATE IN THE COUNTRY FOR THE
LAST SIX DECADES THE VALUE OF
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN PRODUCTION
WAS ROUGHLY FORTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS.
THERE ARE MORE THAN SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND FARMS AND RANCHES AND
CUT IN CALIFORNIA. AND SEVENTY
NINE PERCENT OF THE FARMS ARE
INDIVIDUAL OR FAMILY OWNED.
THESE FARMS PRODUCE MORE THAN
FOUR HUNDRED FOOD COMMODITIES IN
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY STATE IN
THE COUNTRY. THE PRODUCES FIGS
ALMONDS KIWI FRUIT PISTACHIOS
OLIVES RAISINS AND ARTICHOKES
JUST TO NAME A FEW.
THIS MEANS THAT PRODUCTION CAN
CREATE JOBS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY AS WELL
TRUCKERS TRAINS PORT SHIPPING.
ALL GOOD PAYING IMPORTANT JOBS
FOR FOLKS WHO LIVE IN URBAN
AREAS AS WELL.
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES BENEFIT.
AS I SAID ON TUESDAY CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE WILL BE ON DISPLAY
ON THE WEBSITE WEST STEPS OF THE
CAPITOL.
ALL OF THE STAFF OF THE CAPITAL
WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VISIT THE EXHIBITS THAT PROVIDE
FREE THE BOUNTY OF CALIFORNIA'S
FARMS AND RANCHES.
PLEASE ENJOY THIS BUT ALSO TAKE
THE TIME TO THANK THE FARMING
FAMILIES FOR THEIR HARD WORK AND
COMMITMENT TO SOME OF THE
HIGHEST QUALITY.
A MOST DELICIOUS FOOD IN THE
WORLD.
REFLECT ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS INDUSTRY TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY.
AND UNDERSTAND THAT WE NEED TO
LISTEN TO FARMERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
MANY OF WHOM HAVE BEEN A
DEDICATED SEVERAL GENERATIONS TO
GROWING THE FOOD THAT YOU AND I
ALL ENJOY SO MUCH.
WE NEED TO PARTNER WITH OUR
FARMERS SO THAT POLICIES THAT
ARE GOOD FOR THE STATE ARE ALSO
GOOD FOR FARMERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK MADAM
SPEAKER THAT THE FIRST ROLL CALL
BE FOR CO AUTHORS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
BUT MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AGRICULTURAL DAY. AS THE VICE
CHAIRMAN OF AG AND THE MEMBER
THAT REPRESENTS ONE OF THE
LARGEST AGRICULTURAL AREAS. THAT
IS ALSO HOME OF THE WORLD AG
EXPO.
AGRICULTURE IS IN JUST ABOUT THE
FOOD WE.
IT'S THE CLOTHES YOU'RE WEARING.
IT'S EVERYTHING THAT'S AROUND
YOU ALL THE THINGS THAT YOU HAVE
THE YOU ENJOY THAT YOU TAKE FOR
GRANTED.
WAS GROWN BY THE HANDS OF
FARMERS.
AND RANCHERS.
IN DAIRY MEN.
PEOPLE WHOSE ENTIRE CULTURE
THEIR ENTIRE HERITAGE.
TO THE LAND.
WORKING WITH MOTHER NATURE AND
PROVIDING THESE THINGS.
THAT MOST OF US JUST THINK COME
FROM GROCERY STORES.
AND SOME OF OUR NEW GENERATION
JUST THINK THEY CAN ORDER IT
FROM MY NAP ON A PHONE.
BUT WE MUST REMEMBER. OUR
AGRICULTURAL HERITAGE.
BECAUSE IT IS TOUGH TIMES WE
HAVE TO LISTEN TO THEM.
IN VIEW IT FROM THEIR POINT.
WE GET CAUGHT UP UP HERE UNDER
THE DOME.
THE IN EL AGRICULTURE JUST OVER
THERE OR WE CAN IMPORTER FOOD
FROM SOMEWHERE ELSE. BUT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE SOME OF THE
SMARTEST
CLEANEST FRESHEST.
MOST IN THE MOST FRIGID
CONDITIONS TO GROW.
BUT OUR FOOD IS THE BEST IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD.
OUR AGRICULTURAL HERE IN THIS
STATE IS WHAT MAKES US THE BEST
STATE. NOT ONLY IN THE COUNTRY
BUT IN THE WORLD.
WE PROVIDE MORAG THAN ANYBODY
ELSE.
AND WE NEED TO REMEMBER THAT.
AND WE NEED TO REMEMBER.
THE HARD WORK THAT THESE GUYS GO
THROUGH THE THINGS THAT THEY GO
THROUGH AND AS WE PASSED
LEGISLATION IN THIS HOUSE.
WE NEED TO PAY ATTENTION TO
THAT.
IN TAKE THEIR WORD. THEIR
EXPERIENCE.
FROM GENERATIONS.
I PUT THAT IN THE LANGUAGE OF
WHAT WE DO.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THE
STATE I LOOK FOR TO SEEING YOU
TOMORROW.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
HR EIGHTY FOUR. NOT TO BE
REDUNDANT.
AND RE STATE.
COMMENTS HAD BEEN MADE BY BOTH
THE AUTHOR AND OUR COLLEAGUE.
FROM THE PORT OF LA AREA BUT TO
REALLY HIGHLIGHT.
HOW IT TRICKLE THIS CONVERSATION
OF?
AG IS TO A WHOLE. HOST OF OTHER
AREAS.
I'LL START WITH WATER.
AND HOW CRITICAL IT IS THAT WE.
ENSURE THAT HER INVESTMENTS
INTO OUR WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
OUR STRATEGIC ANY MADE. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONTINUING.
GROW THE AG ECONOMY OF
CALIFORNIA.
ALSO MENTION AND I THINK IT BE
REMISS IF WE DIDN'T.
ACKNOWLEDGE AND CELEBRATE.
FARMWORKERS.
THAT FARM WORKERS AND FARMERS
HANDING GLOVE.
ARE TRULY WHAT MAKE.
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURE.
THE BEST
THERE IS TO OFFER.
AND WHEN I TALK ABOUT
FARMWORKERS
I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE NEED
THAT EXIST UP AND DOWN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
TO ADDRESS THE SHORTAGES.
THAT ARE IN PARTICULAR PLACES
LIKE MY COLLEAGUES HAVE JUST
SPOKEN IN OUR OWN BACKYARD AND
BROUGH COUNTY. THE LABOR
SHORTAGES THAT EXIST THAT PUT AT
RISK.
THIS DRIVING ECONOMY.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IT REALLY.
THAT TIES INTO.
WHAT IS AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION? FROM HERE ALL THE
WAY DOWN TO WASHINGTON DC. AND
THAT'S IMMIGRATION.
POLICY.
THAT KEEPS IN MIND.
THE STRONG ECONOMIES
SUCH AS THE AG ECONOMY IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THE NEED TO HAVE
SOME COMPREHENSIVE POLICY.
THAT INSURERS.
THAT THEIR CONTINUES TO BE A
SUSTAINABLE WORKFORCE.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF SUPPORTING.
OUR AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO IN CELEBRATION.
OF AG DAY.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ALSO
KEEP IN MIND THESE OTHER IT
TRICKLE ELEMENTS THAT FALL INTO
PLACE. AND ULTIMATELY
MAKE CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
THE THRIVING INDUSTRY THAT IT IS
FOR ALL OF US HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU BUT TO THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I'M PLEASED TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS AND I RISE
MORE JUST TO TALK ABOUT THE
PLACE OF AGRICULTURE.
SURROUNDED US IN THIS PLACE FOR
WE DO WORK.
SO I'D BE RISKS REMISS IF I
FAILED TO POINT OUT.
THAT ON THE WEST PORTICO.
DECORATED THE EXTERIOR OF THE
WEST PARTICLE BEHIND THOSE
COLUMNS.
OUR SERIES OF BANNERS.
THEY'RE MADE OF AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCE.
SO YOU APPROACH TO BUILDING YOU
WOULD SEE IT THERE.
IF YOU GO UP TO THE HEAD OF THE
STAIRCASE RIGHT OVER HERE. THE
CENTER DOORS TO LOOK UP CAPITOL
MALL.
ARE THE ONLY SET OF RITUAL DOORS
IN THE BUILDING.
THAT'S WHERE YOU'LL SEE THE
BUNDLE OF STICKS IN THE WOOD OF
THE DOORS.
YOU WILL SEE THE WISE OLD OWL
YOU'LL SEE ALL MANNER OF THINGS
WE WILL SEE CARD WHAT OF THESE
DORSEN REVERSAL STATE CAPITOL IN
THE SECOND FLOOR. A BANNER.
THE PRICE OF OUR CULTURAL
PRODUCTS.
WHEN YOU STAND IN THE ROTUNDA
AND LOOK UP AT THE WALL UP THERE
BENEATH THOSE WINDOWS YOU SEE
THOSE SIXTEEN COLUMNS.
AND AHEAD OF EVERYONE OF THOSE
COLUMNS THERE ARE THIRTY TWO.
HORNS OF PLENTY.
CORNUCOPIAS
WE DECORATE THE UPPER WALL OF
THE ROTUNDA NOT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FEET AWAY.
BUT WITH THESE THIRTY TWO
CORNUCOPIAS THE FORM THEMSELVES
BANNERS OF AGRICULTURAL PROGRAM.
DECORATING OUR CAPITAL.
AND THEN ON THE FOUR POINTS OF
THE COMPASS OFF THE ROTUNDA
WHERE ATHENA.
IS PRESENT
YOU WILL ALSO SEE DECORATIONS OF
OUR GRAPES FROM OUR STATE.
STILL THIS CELEBRATION OF AG
PRODUCTS IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
BEEN A PART OF OUR UNIQUE FABRIC
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
FOR SO LONG.
AND A RESOLUTION LIKE THIS IS
VERY GOOD ON THIS FOR BECAUSE IT
IS.
THROUGHOUT ARE CAPITAL WE
CELEBRATE THIS ASPECT OF OUR
ECONOMY.
IS VITAL NOT JUST TO
CALIFORNIANS PUT TO OUR NATION
AND INDEED THE WHOLE GLOW. SO
SELANNE RISE IN SUPPORT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY.
THEY YOU BETTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AYE RISES UP. SOMEBODY WHO HAS
AG DAY EVERY DAY. AS A FARMER
IN.
THE LEGISLATURE I APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THIS.
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION FORWARD
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
SHARING.
.
WITH MEMBERS AS THEY COME TO MY
DISTRICT ARE ARE EIGHTY EIGHT
YEARS OF MY FAMILY.
MIDDLE THE FARM IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I WANT TO JUST UP TO BE ABLE
TO. CARRY ON THAT TRADITION WITH
MY SON WHO WAS HERE LAST WEEK I
GOT THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
THAT.
YEAH HE'S IN THE FFA AND AND DO
IN CT  WHICH WE I KNOW IS A.
A A HIGH PRIORITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE SO I JUST WANT TO.
STAND UP AND SAY AS A FARMER IN
CALIFORNIA AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
HOPEFULLY CONTINUE THAT UP. TO
THE FIFTH FOURTH AND. FIFTH AND
SIX GENERATIONS OF OUR FAMILY
OUT THANK YOU FOR BEING THIS
FORWARD AND IT'S A. AND DOORS
THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN
EUROPE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES MADAM SPEAKER I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR STANDING
UP IN SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION
AND TO SAY THAT. COULD MAKE THE
COMMITMENT THAT I'D LIKE TO SEE
THE FOURTH AND FIFTH GENERATION
CONTINUE AS WELL ON IT'S
IMPORTANT OUR STATE IT'S MORE
IMPORTANT.
.
TO OUR STATE I THINK THAT MANY
REALIZE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE AND THE FIRST ROLL
CALL TO BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE FIRST OFFERS. THIS
RULES FOR COOPERS.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL DAY RESOLUTION.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY SIX CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS.
SPEAKER ABOVE WHERE I'M STANDING
HERE. NOW WE HAVE A GROUP FROM
IMPERIAL COUNTY.
THAT ARE LED BY GO MEET THIS CD
CALLED IN BY IT.
IT IS A YOUTH ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH INTERNSHIP PROGRAM. WHICH
IS FOCUSED ON ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE.
AIR MONITORING IN HELPING HOMES.
IN IMPERIAL COUNTY THE PROGRAM
IS MADE UP OF ELEVEN HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS RANGING FROM NINE.
TO TWELFTH GRADE THEY ARE COMING
FROM CALEXICO AYE SCHOOL.
DEAR OLD HIGH SCHOOL BROUGHT
HIGH SCHOOL CENTRAL SOUTHWEST.
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO KILEY POPPEA
PLEASE HELP ME WELCOME THEM TO
THE STATE CAPITOL COLLEAGUES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MA'AM. I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE UP PARENTS UNITED FOR
KIDS.
WHICH IS AN ORGANIZATION
COMPRISED OF INDIVIDUALS FROM MY
DISTRICT AND ACROSS CALIFORNIA
YOU SEE HIM STANDING IN THE
BACK.
PERCHING NIGHT FOR KIDS IS A
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATION THAT WAS
FOUNDED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WHAT
THE GOALS OF SERVING THE NEEDS
OF FAMILIES.
THE ORGANIZATION IS COMMITTED TO
SUPPORTING CANADA TO LEGISLATION
THAT COURAGEOUSLY SERVES TO
PROTECT. THE RIGHTS OF PARENTS
IN CALIFORNIA.
I WANT TO THANK PARENTS UNITED
FOR KIDS FOR THEIR.
CONTINUOUS ADVOCACY FOR FAMILIES
RIGHTS OF PARENTAL CHOICE LIKE
YOUR BUDDY.
MEMBERS WE ARE JOINED TODAY BY A
FORMER MEMBER OF THIS THE
ASSEMBLY PLEASE WELCOME. FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FIONA MA
.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM TEN AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY SIX MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FORTY
SIX WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING
MEMBERSHIP ON SAYS.
SOME MEMBERS CERVANTES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER TODAY AND PRESENTED
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN FORTY SIX THIS BILL
EXPEDITES THE PROCESS OF
PROSECUTING CASES OF SARAH.
SERIAL SEXUAL BATTERY IN
STATUTORY RAPE THAT OCCUR
MULTIPLE COUNTIES THESE
AMENDMENTS MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES IN OUT SEVERAL CAUGHT
THERE SHOULD THE BILL COLLEAGUES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS AND TO
SEND THE BILL BACK OUT TO PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE.
THANK YOU THERE IS NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE AMENDMENTS
ALTHOUGH WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THIS ITEM ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR PLEASE SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED.
THEY'LL BE OUT OF PRINT AND BACK
ON FILE.
ITEM ELEVEN ACR ONE FORTY FIVE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FORTY FIVE BY SOMETHING
NUMBER LACKEY AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE FOR AEROSPACE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY ARE
RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I KNOW PROUD TO TO PRESENT DAY
SHE ARE ONE FORTY FIVE WHICH
EXPRESSES SUPPORT FOR THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. TO ESTABLISH A
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR
AEROSPACE IN THE ADULT VALLEY.
THIS IS A TOOL REBRAND
CALIFORNIA'S AEROSPACE STATE.
IT WILL ENSURE THAT WE'RE
ATTRACTING AND RETAINING THE
BEST AND BRIGHTEST STUDENTS ARE
UNIVERSITIES HAVE TO OFFER.
IT WILL SERVE TO PROMOTE A
PIPELINE FOR THE NEXT GENERATION
OF AEROSPACE ENGINEERS WITH
STUDENTS BEING ABLE TO.
DO HANDS ON RESEARCH WITH
DEFENSE A PRIVATE INDUSTRY
PARTNERS.
BUT THE EXPERIENCE AND EXPERTISE
THE US TO OFFER. OUR STUDENTS
WILL GRADUATE AND FINE MORTGAGE
PAYING JOBS IN THEIR FIELD RIGHT
HERE IN OUR STATE.
THIS REGION HAS SERVED THE U. S.
AIR FORCE AND INDUSTRY PARTNERS.
FOR WELL OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
DECADES WE BELIEVE THAT THE
CREATION OF CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE
FOR AEROSPACE.
SHE IS MARROW SPACES EXACTLY
WHAT IS NEEDED.
PROPEL THE INDUSTRY FORWARD.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ACOSTA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MEDI SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ACR ONE FORTY FIVE.
THE SENATE PRETTY VALLEY HAS
THE LARGEST HUB OF AEROSPACE
MANUFACTURERS IN THE STATE.
AND I BELIEVE THE INSTITUTE
WOULD SERVE TO BOOST THE ECONOMY
IN THE REGION AND SERVE TO ALL
ULTIMATELY SUPPORT JOB GROWTH.
IN THE INDUSTRY.
THE INSTITUTE WILL SUPPORT
AEROSPACE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT. AND ATTRACT THE
BEST AND THE BRIGHTEST IN THE
FIELD.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU AND I URGE MY VOTE.
SO MEMBER WEBER YOUR RECOGNIZED.
YES MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE
FORTY FIVE AND THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ANTELOPE VALLEY.
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD.
YOU KNOW WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT THE
GREATNESS OF CALIFORNIA AND THIS
IS A GREAT STATE WE JUST HEARD
ABOUT THE AGRICULTURAL ASPECTS
OF CALIFORNIA THAT IS SECOND TO
NONE.
AND THAT'S THE BEAUTY OF THIS
STATE IS WE HAVE SOME OF
EVERYTHING BUT MORE IMPORTANT WE
HAVE EVERYTHING THAT WE DO RIGH
IN FIRST CLASS.
AND I REALLY SUPPORT THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT MANY OF OUR
INSTITUTES HAVE BEEN. INJURED
ENGINES FOR ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AS WELL AS ACADEMIC RESEARCH AND
WE ALWAYS ON THE CUTTING EDGE
AND IT SEEMS STRANGE THAT WE
WOULDN'T HAVE THIS INSTITUTE IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT IT'S GREAT THAT
WE DO BECAUSE WHEN WE LOOK AT
ALL OF OUR INSTITUTES WHETHER
THOSE THAT WHAT'S IT STEP
PROCESS STANFORD OF. THE
BERKELEY WHERE YOU GO DOWN TO
SAN DIEGO AND YOU SEE THE
OCEANOGRAPHY IN THE INSTANCE
SCRIPPS INSTITUTE FAIR AND ALL
THOSE THINGS BASICALLY DRIVE
THOSE INSTITUTIONS.
DR OUR STUDENTS TO BE EXCELLENT
CREATE JOBS FOR US AND KEEP
CALIFORNIA BASICALLY THE THE THE
BEST STATE IN THE UNION SO I
REALLY SUPPORT ACR ONE FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD IT'S ABOUT TIME THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YEAH I'D LIKE TO I THINK BOTH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM SAN DIEGO SENATE
LEADER FOR THEIR SUPPORT IN THIS
MEASURE. AND I'M EXCITED.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA SO TWO
DIFFERENT SPACE TO GET OFF THE
GROUND. AND ASK FOR.
THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE FOR CAR.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR
COAUTHORS.
S. RULES FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE. THEY'RE SIXTY FIVE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ITEMS TWELVE AND THIRTEEN PASS
AND RETAIN MOVING TO ITEM
FOURTEEN ACR ONE AB THREE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE EIGHTY THREE BY SOME
REMEMBER CARILLO RELATIVE TO THE
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
CHICANO STUDENT WALKOUTS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COMING YEAR ARE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
SO I CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES.
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION A ONE
EIGHTY THREE. A RESOLUTION
COMMEMORATING THE FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE CHICANO LOCK
OUT IN LOS ANGELES.
FIFTY YEARS AGO THIS MONTH.
THE BRAVE CHICANO MEXICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS OF LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WARREN
DURING SOME OF THE MOST
SHAMEFUL.
EDUCATIONAL CONDITION THE STATE
HAS SEEN.
DECADES OF INSTITUTIONALIZED
RACISM CREATED AN ENVIRONMENT
RIPE AND PREDISPOSED.
TWO BIASES AND STEREOTYPING.
AND STRIP STUDENTS OF THEIR
BASIC DIGNITY.
STUDENTS WERE FORCED.
OR FORBIDDEN I'M SORRY FROM
SPEAKING SPANISH
BATHROOMS WERE LOCKED DURING
RECESS AND LUNCH.
AND STUDENTS ARE MADE TO FEEL
LIKE SECOND CLASS CITIZENS.
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME BEING
DRAFTED INTO THE VIETNAM WAR AS
SOON AS THEY WERE EIGHTEEN.
SUBJECTS GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL.
THE SCHOOLS WERE RUNDOWN. LACKED
COLLEGE PREP COURSES AND LACK
TEACHERS OF COLOR WHO UNDERSTOOD
THE COMPLEXITIES OF THE STUDENT
BODY.
THIS LED TO SOME OF THE WORST
HIGH SCHOOL DROPOUT RATES.
THIS NATION HAS SEEN
SOME AS HIGH AS FIFTY SEVEN
PERCENT. ARE AT GARFIELD HIGH
SCHOOL IN EAST LA.
IN MANY WAYS.
THE SYSTEM HAD GIVEN UP ON THESE
KIDS BUT THEY HAD NOT GIVEN UP
ON THEMSELVES.
AIDED BY YOUNG CHICANO TEACHER
NAMED SAL CASTRO.
WHO LEFT US A FEW YEARS AGO?
A GROUP OF YOUNG PEOPLE KNOWN AS
THE BROWN BERETS.
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND HIGH SCHOOL
RECRUITS.
THEY ALL WORK TOGETHER.
TO ORGANIZE THE WALKOUTS
TWO PROTESTS THE INJUSTICE.
OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES AND CALL
ATTENTION TO THEIR DEMANDS FOR
CHANGE EQUITY JUSTICE AND
OPPORTUNITY.
MORE THAN FIFTEEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS FROM HIGH SCHOOLS AND
MIDDLE SCHOOLS ACROSS THE EAST
SIDE OF LOS ANGELES WALKED OUT.
TO DEMAND SMALLER CLASSES.
MORE BILINGUAL COUNSELORS AND
EDUCATORS AND INSTRUCTORS
LESSONS ON MEXICAN AMERICAN
CULTURE ART AND HISTORY WHICH
WOULD NOW KNOW TO BE ETHNIC
STUDIES.
BUT THE WALKOUTS WERE NOT
SMOOTHLY. RUN FOR EVERYONE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT RESPONDED WITH
RAIDS AND ARRESTS INCLUDING
ARRESTS LEE ARRESTING AND
FALSELY IMPRISONING. THIRTEEN
STUDENTS
DURING AT THAT TIME WHICH THEIR
TRIAL LATER BECAME KNOWN AS THE
EAST SIDE THIRTEEN.
THEY WERE EVENTUALLY RELEASED
BUT THEY LEFT THEIR MARK IN
HISTORY.
BUT YOU GOTTA WALK OUT ALONG
WITH THE CHICANO MORATORIUM
AGAINST THE VIETNAM WAR WERE A
MAJOR DEMONSTRATION THAT
MIRRORED.
THE SITUATION AND ISSUES OF THAT
TIME INCLUDING THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT.
THIS STUDENT LED MOVEMENT OF
FIFTY YEARS AGO.
LED BY STUDENTS.
ORGANIZED BY STUDENTS.
AND ULTIMATELY IMPACTING ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
ASPIRE TO TODAY.
THEY DID IT FIFTY YEARS AGO WHEN
THERE WAS NO SOCIAL MEDIA. NO
TWITTER.
AND SO WE'RE ABLE TO ORGANIZE.
I BROUGHT THIS RESOLUTION TO
THIS BODY TODAY TO HONOR THE
HISTORY. OF THAT STUDENT LED
MOVEMENT.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
RECOGNIZE.
THE CYCLES OF HISTORY INSPIRING
THE GENERATIONS TODAY.
THE FIGHT FOR EQUITY JUSTICE
OPPORTUNITY CONTINUES.
AND ORGANIZING OF OUR
COMMUNITIES CONTINUES TO BE A
CRITICAL PART. OF THAT FIGHT.
WE HAVE SEEN TWO MILLION
STUDENTS THAT WALKED OUT LAST
WEEK.
IN THEIR FIGHT FOR.
THEIR OWN PROTECTION AT THEIR
SCHOOLS AND AGAINST GUN
VIOLENCE.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE RECOGNIZE
THE HISTORY AND CONTRIBUTIONS OF
CHICANOS AND MEXICAN AMERICANS
AND LATINOS ACROSS THE STATE.
BECAUSE THAT'S CALIFORNIA GOES
SO DOES THE NATION.
THANK YOU AND I URGE YOU AND I
VOTE FOR ACR ONE EIGHTY THREE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE
EIGHTY THREE AND I THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES TO
BRINGING. OF THIS RESOLUTION
FORWARD.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT I WAS A
FRESHMAN.
I WAS A FRESHMAN IN HIGH SCHOOL
IN NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT ONE
HUNDRED MILES AWAY. FROM LOS
ANGELES.
THE TOWN OF.
AYE POPULATION FIVE THOUSAND.
ATTENDING CATHOLIC SCHOOL.
AND ALTHOUGH I.
DID NOT ATTEND HIGH SCHOOL IN
LOS ANGELES.
I FACED.
AS MANY STUDENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIAN THIS NATION FACE.
THE SAME LIMITATIONS.
THE SAME LOW EXPECTATIONS
FROM TEACHERS
AND I REMEMBER.
CATHOLIC PRIEST.
IN MY SCHOOL WHO SAID TO MY
PARENTS THAT I WASN'T COLLEGE
MATERIAL.
BECAUSE MY ENGLISH BEING.
SPANISH SPEAKER UP WAS NOT GOOD
ENOUGH.
SO WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE TODAY
WHAT WAS DONE FIFTY YEARS AGO
AND EAST LOS ANGELES CHANGE
HISTORY.
AND THE STUDENTS ARE HERE WITH
US TODAY.
HELP LEAD THAT.
MARCH THAT WALK OUT OUT OF THE
EAST LA SCHOOLS
CHANGED HISTORY.
AN IMPORTANT PART OF HISTORY OF
THIS NATION.
AND AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO A. REMINDS IS.
OFTEN.
THAT HISTORY OF ONE GROUP IS THE
HISTORY OF ALL OF US.
AND IS CHEECH MUDDYING SAYS OF
CHICANO ART IT IS AMERICAN ART
SO IS THE HISTORY. OF THE
CHICANO MOVEMENT AMERICAN
HISTORY.
SO IT IS MY HONOR TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION.
AND. TO USE A PROP.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
I HAVE WITH ME HERE.
THE BOOK BLOW OUT.
BY.
HISTORIAN MY AUDIO GARCIA AND
SAL CASTRO.
PERMISSION TO RE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
IN THE BOOK IT SAYS
SO WHO IS SAU CASTRO.
HIS A MAJOR FIGURE IN U. S.
EDUCATIONAL HISTORY.
IN US CIVIL RIGHTS HISTORY.
AND AND CHICANO HISTORY.
HE IS A MAJOR AMERICAN LEADER
AND ONE WHO DESERVES JESS
RECOGNITION.
HE DESERVES HIS PLACE IN THE
PANTHEON. OF KEY CHICANO
MOVEMENT ERA FIGURES.
SUCH AS SISTER CHAVEZ.
THE LOTUS WENT THAT. RUBIN
SALAZAR BERT CORONA CORKY
GONZALEZ AND REYES LOPEZ THEY
HAD ENOUGH.
SO.
AS WE.
HONOR.
AND REMEMBER THE FIFTY YEAR WALK
OUT FIFTY YEARS AGO IN LOS
ANGELES.
LET US REMEMBER THAT THIS
STRUGGLE IS STILL IMPORTANT THAT
THE HISTORYOF THIS STRUGGLE IS
IMPORTANT.
UP MY HONOR AND ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT ACR ONE EIGHTY THREE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SCHABAS.
YOU KNOW HEARING THE DISCUSSION
TODAY.
.
I THOUGHT I WOULD ALSO RISE UP
THE GIVE A NOTHER CONTEXT TO IT.
HISTORY IS COMPLEX.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT. I WAS
AT. A PUBLIC SCHOOL NOT A
CATHOLIC SCHOOL.
I TOWARDS HIGH SCHOOL.
I WAS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
JUNIOR CLASS AT MY HIGH SCHOOL.
IN SIXTY EIGHT I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REPRESENT
CALIFORNIANS OLYMPIC TRIALS IN
WRESTLING.
AND MY TEACHERS WHO.
GAVE ME THE DIRECTION AN
OPPORTUNITY BE SUCCESSFUL IN
SCHOOL.
OR SUCCESSFUL OF THE SPORTS.
WE'RE NOT LATINO.
THIS WAS A COMPLEX TIME AND
THERE WERE AREAS POSSIBLY EVEN
JUSTICE BUT THEY'RE ALSO PACES.
OF JUSTICE.
AND I FIND IT INTERESTING WHEN
WE START USING TERMS AND LABELS
SCHOOL. MY FATHER WAS A MIGRANT
WORK AND YOU'VE HEARD THE START
OF FOR HE WENT FOR THE FAILED TO
FIGHT IN WORLD WAR TWO AFTER.
PEARL HARBOR.
WAS WORKING AT THE U. S. STILL
MALES BUT THROUGH THE GI BILL
WAS ABLE TO GO TO A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
A JUNIOR COLLEGE
AND TAKE US FROM THE.
BODY ARE TO TORRANCE CALIFORNIA
AT THE AGE YOUR OF UP I WAS
ABOUT SIX.
BUT I WAS VALUE OF EDUCATION SO
THAT'S WHY I'M ALWAYS FOCUS ON
EDUCATION BUT WHEN I FILL OUT A
CARD THEY SAID.
AUG.
YOU'RE A MEXICAN AMERICAN AND MY
FATHER WROTE ON THE CARD YOU
SAID NO YOU'RE AMERICAN YOU SAID
I FOUGHT. A WAR IN WORLD WAR TWO
TO ENSURE THAT YOU WOULD BE. AN
AMERICAN.
AND I THINK IT'S IT TRUST YOU
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY OF A PICTURE
OF HIM WHEN HE WAS GOING OFF
FROM BOOT CAMP. IN BEHIND HIM
THIS PICTURE IN HIS UNIFORM WAS
A FLAG OF MEXICO AND THE FLAG OF
THE UNITED STATES.
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT HE GAVE
HIS GRANDMOTHER.
THAT'S COMPLEX BUT THAT'S
ACTUALLY WHAT OUR HISTORIES
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW I WENT FROM I A MEXICAN
AMERICAN TO AMERICAN TO CHICANO.
TO WILL A LATINO TO HISPANIC AND
ICE JOKE AROUND YOU KNOW AT NO
TIME DID I EVER CHANGE MY NAME
WHO I WAS WHO I THOUGHT I WAS.
BUT PEOPLE STARTED TELLING ME
WHO I WAS AND WHAT WAS GOING ON
WITH MY LIFE.
IS THERE A JUSTICE IN THE WORLD
YES THERE IS INJUSTICE GOING ON
RIGHT NOW TODAY PROBABLY NOT
ONLY IN OUR COMMUNITIES BUT I
SUGGEST YOU AROUND THE WORLD.
BUT WE SHOULD NOT.
PAINT STATE A CALIFORNIA AS ONE
THAT HAD THIS BIG TURMOIL AT THE
TIME BECAUSE THERE WERE LITTLE
GUYS LIKE ME NAME CHAVEZ.
WHO WAS GIVEN ALL THE
OPPORTUNITY THE WORLD?
BECAUSE OF A LOT OF GREAT
PEOPLE.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
THAT ONE HAS SPENT.
YOU KNOW I JUST ASK YOUR BUDDY
PUT IT IN CONTEXT WHAT'S GOING
ON AYE I'M HERE THE SPEECH IS
GOING OUT THERE. BUT I'M A GUY
THAT ACTUALLY WAS IN NO WAY USED
TO GO PARTY IN THESE DEL A BUT
USED TO SIR. AND MANHATTAN
HERMOSA BEACH AND THE WORLD WAS
MUCH MORE COMPLEX.
THEN WHAT'S BEING PRESENTED.
I WILL NOT BE VOTING FOR THIS
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO.
I'M SORRY US SOME I BEG YOUR
PARDON ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT. OF ACR
ONE EIGHTY THREE.
AND LIKE TODAY.
AS WE SEE YOUNG PEOPLE.
ORGANIZING THEMSELVES AND.
BRINGING ATTENTION TO THE ISSUES
OF. GRAND IMPORTANCE FIFTYYEARS
AGO CHICANO STUDENTS IN EAST LOS
ANGELES WALKED OUT. OTHER
SCHOOLS TO PROTEST INJUSTICE AND
INEQUALITY IN THEIR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
AT THE SAME TIME YOU HAD YOUNG
CHICANOS AND CHICANOS IN MY
DISTRICT.
NOBODY IS A OR CHAT LIVE ROLLEI
INDIA AND CENTRO.
IN SOLIDARITY JOINING.
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE IN EAST LOS
ANGELES.
TWO OUTCRY.
THE INJUSTICES THAT WERE
HAPPENING AND THE INEQUITY AS IT
RELATES TO THE EDUCATION THAT
THEY WERE RECEIVING THEY WERE
FIGHTING FOR.
BILINGUAL AND BICULTURAL
EDUCATION.
THEY WERE ASKING FOR THE
REVISION OF TEXTBOOKS.
THAT TOLD EIGHT ACCURATE STORY
OF HISTORY.
THEY WERE FIGHTING FOR TEACHERS
AND ADMINISTRATORS.
ENSURING THAT THERE WAS DIVERSE
CITY.
BUT THERE WERE PEOPLE WHO LOOK
LIKE THEM.
TEACHING THEM AND ENCOURAGING
THEM.
TO DO GREAT THINGS.
HOWEVER COLLEAGUES FIFTY YEARS
LATER.
YOU KNOW WE'VE MADE SOME
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES BUT WE'VE
GOT A LONG WAY TO GO.
WE STILL HAVE NOT FULFILLED.
THAT DREAM OF THOSE BRAVE YOUNG
PEOPLE UP AND DOWN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AS IT RELATES TO ACHIEVING THOSE
GOALS.
YOU KNOW LATINOS REPRESENT OVER
HALF OF OUR STUDENT POPULATION.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO
SEVENTEEN.
THE ONLY REPRESENTED TWENTY
PERCENT OF THE TEACHERS.
AND TWENTY TWO PERCENT OF
ADMINISTRATORS.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN LATINO
STUDENTS REPRESENTED OVER SIXTY
ONE PERCENT. OF DROPOUTS.
WE GOT SOME WORK TO DO.
I SAW.
IN POOR PERFORMANCE OVER NOT
BEING OF STUDENTS.
WE COULD SAY.
THE SYSTEM.
IT'S NOT WORKING.
IT'S NOT WORKING FOR US.
I LOOK FORWARD.
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH MY
COLLEAGUES TO IDENTIFY AND
ADDRESS.
STRUCTURAL BARRIERS THERE
PREVENTING OUR LATINO YOUTH FROM
ACHIEVING THEIR FULL POTENTIAL.
I WANNA THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FROM THE EAGLE ROCK COMMUNITIES
FOR BRINGING FORWARD TO SUPPORT
RESOLUTION ALSO WANT TO THANK.
YOUR GUESS WHO YOU WILL BE
INTRODUCING A AFTER THIS
RESOLUTION BECAUSE. THEY TRULY
ARE.
HEROES AND SHE ROES
FOR MANY YOUNG CHICANOS AND SHE
GOT ME DOES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA COULD IN THE
FIFTY SIX SEVEN DISTRICT.
THANK YOU SOMEWHERE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AYE AYE RISE AND THANK
MY COLLEAGUE.
.
FROM THE LOS ANGELES AREA FOR
BRINGING FORTH ACR ONE EIGHTY
THREE.
YOU KNOW HISTORY IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT WE'VESPENT TIME TOO
COSTLY TALKING ABOUT WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH AND. AND BLACK
HISTORY MONTH AND ALL THOSE
OTHER KINDS OF THINGS. AND PART
OF IT IS OBVIOUSLY A PROCESS OF
US.
UNDERSTANDING ARE PAST THAT
MAKES A STRONG.
UNDERSTANDING ARE PASSIVE
HOPEFULLY HELPS US TO PREVENT
MAKING THE MISTAKES AGAIN.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY KEEPING US
ON TRACK AM SENSITIZING US OF
THE VALUE WAITING WHERE WE ARE
WHERE WE'VE BEEN AND WHERE WE
HAVE TO GO.
AND I THINK IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED FIFTY YEARS AGO.
HOW OUR STUDENTS ROSE UP TO
PROTEST?
AND I REMEMBER THOSE DAYS I WAS
AT THE UNIVERSITY ACTUALLY FIFTY
YEARS AGO.
AND I REMEMBER ALL THE PROTESTS
THAT TOOK PLACE AND HOW HOW
VALUABLE THOSE PROTESTS WORRY Y.
IN CENTER RING US AS A NATION.
AND MAKING US AND REMINDING US
OF THE CONTINUING STRUGGLE TO
WHAT TO BECOME THE MORE PERFECT
UNION.
THE NEVER REACH PERFECTION BUT
ALWAYS WORKING TO BECOME THE
MORE PERFECT UNION BECAUSE WHY
BECAUSE WE'RE HUMAN.
AND WE MAKE MISTAKES
AND WE OFTENTIMES DON'T SEE
OTHERS WHO DON'T LOOK LIKE US
AND DON'T STRUGGLE LIKE US.
AND AS THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT
BEEN WHO MUST BRING US BACK TO
WHERE WE ARE.
OFTENTIMES WE HAVE LEAD THE
CHALLENGE THAT'S HERE IN THE END
THEY THAT THAT NIGHT IN FIFTY
YEARS AGO THEY OFFER THAT
CHALLENGE.
AND THEY SPARKED OFTENTIMES A
VOICE FOR SO MANY OTHERS IN
SIMILAR CIRCUMSTANCES SO THAT WE
FOUND THE PROTEST AT THE
UNIVERSITIES AND WE FOUND BLACK
STUDIES IN NINETEEN SIXTY NINE.
AND SIXTY EIGHT THOSE PROTESTS
WERE GOING ON OUR STUDENTS WERE
RISING UP EVERYWHERE.
AND IF YOU ON THE COLLEGE CAMPUS
IT WAS AN EXCITING TIME TO BE
THERE.
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT A CHANCE THE
HAVE A VOICE AS A YOUNG PERSON.
AND HAVE THAT VOICE HEARD AND
THAT'S WHAT OUR STUDENTS ALSO
DID LAST WEEK. THEY HAD A VOICE
AND THEY WERE HEARD AND THEY
WILL CONTINUE TO BE HEARD AND
THEY HAVE A VOICE AND AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THINGS THAT
MANY OF US WOULD LOVE TO DO BUT
ARE AFRAID TO DO WHY. BECAUSE WE
HAVE MORTGAGES WE HAVE BILLS WE
HAVE RESPONSIBILITY AND THIS IS
THE ONE TIME MOST FOLKS REALIZE
IN THAT LIES WHEN I WAS A
STUDENT I WAS TOLD. THIS IS THE
ONE TIME YOU CAN REALLY REYES
HILL.
YOU CAN BE THE PERSON YOU WANNA
BE YOU CAN RAISE THE ISSUES AND
THE OTHERS WHO ARE HESITANT WILL
HEAR YOU AND THEY WILL RESPOND.
SO WE ARE NOW FACED WITH FIFTY
YEARS OF AN ASSESSMENT.
AND WE SHOULD GO AND WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND HOW HORRIBLE IT WAS
IN THE PAST WE SEE THE PROGRESS
BEEN MADE BUT WE ALSO KNOW AS WE
LOOK AT THE CURRENT REPORTS THAT
ARE OUT TODAY. THAT WE STILL
HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO.
THEY JUST DID THE MAJORITY
REPORT IN TERMS OF EDUCATION OF
LATINOS WE HAD BLACK MINDS
MATTER. IN ENDS IN AND A REPORT
AND WHAT IT SAYS IS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE IN THESE
ISSUES AROUND EDUCATION AROUND
PEOPLE OF COLOR. WE SHOULD NEVER
FORGET THAT AND THIS IS A
REMINDER OF THAT AND WHILE SOME
OF US HAVE BEEN FORTUNATE. I WAS
FORTUNATE EVEN THOUGH I WANTED
ALL SEGREGATED SCHOOLS IN LOS
ANGELES I WAS FORTUNATE TO HAVE
TEACHERS THE MISSISSIPPI ALABAMA
GEORGIA. WHO UNDERSTOOD WHAT THE
BATTLE WAS ALL ABOUT?
AND EDUCATED US IN THE PROJECTS
TO THE HIGHEST LEVEL I WAS
FORTUNATE TO DO THAT.
BUT ALSO READ ABOUT FREDERICK
DOUGLASS WHO REMINDED HIMSELF OF
THE REST OF US BUT IF I FORGET
THE OLD JERUSALEM.
IF I FORGET THE BLEEDING
CHILDREN OF SORROW THAT MAY MY
RIGHT HAND FORGET A CUNNING AND
MAY MY TONGUE CLEAVE TO THE ROOF
OF MY MOUTH.
WHICH MEANS THOSE OF US WHO
BASICALLY BENEFIT AND MOVE
FORWARD WE CANNOT FORGET THEM
ONCE WE HAVE COME. AND WE HAVE
COULD NOT FORGET THOSE WHO ARE
STILL LEFT BEHIND AND WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE IN THIS
HOUSE
REGARDLESS OF WHAT WE HAVE IS
OUR OWN BENEFITS. THE CONSULATE
RAISE A VOICE
SOME I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD
TO REMIND US OF WHERE WE'VE
BEEN.
A FEW STEPS WE MAY FORWARD BUT
ALSO NEVER GO BACK
AND TO CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD
I HOPE THE ALL OF US WILL BOTH
FOR THIS ACR BECAUSE IT REALLY
IS A RECOGNITION OF OUR HISTORY.
OUR CHALLENGE FOR THE FUTURE
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU I SEE NO FURTHER
DEBATER DISCUSSION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUBBY EURO TIME SORRY
CARILLO.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE WOULD
YOU LIKE AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
YES MADAM SPEAKER I ASK THE
ROLE COULD BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A YES VOTE.
THANK YOU.
BUT A QUIRK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
FOR.
MEMBERS.
THIS ROLE IS FOR COAL AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
HE THROWS HER CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
BUT A QUIRK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY FOUR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
SEE NO OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY THIS
BY SAYING I.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COULD A CURIO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GUESTS INTRODUCTIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES. TO ECHO
THE NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT WORDS
OF LINCOLN HIGH SCHOOL TEACHERS
SAL CASTRO MAY HE REST IN POWER.
TODAY IS A BEAUTIFUL DAY TO BE
CHICANO.
JOINING JOINING US TODAY ARE FOR
THE MANY STUDENT LEADERS OF THE
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT FROM
LINCOLN AND GARFIELD HIGH SCHOOL
AN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY ONE.
BOBBY VERDUGO. JULI RIOS JOHN
ART PIECE AND MEET BACKWARD ON
AFTER A LONG FIFTY YEARS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THEM TO THE
PEOPLE'S HOUSE
GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA EVERS GOT GUEST
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
AND RECOGNIZE THE CLASS OF EIGHT
GRADE STUDENTS FROM ST PHILIP
NERI IN THE CITY OF ALAMEDA IN
MY DISTRICT. THERE VISITING THE
CAPITOL TODAY THEY'RE HERE WITH
US IN THE GALLERY LET'S PLEASE
GIVE THEM A WANT ASSEMBLY
WELCOME.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I
AM RE REFERRING AB FOR
SEVENTEEN.
TO THE HEALTH COMMITTEE.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOINT RESEARCH INTO A
THE FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE HEALTH COMMITTEE TO
HEAR AB FOR SEVENTEEN THE MOAN.
AT THEIR HEARING TOMORROW ONE
THIRD.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
I AM FIFTEEN PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING NOW TO
ITEM SIX
TEAM AC ONE NINETY FIVE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OF SORRY THE CLERK
PLEASE MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ
THE ITEM.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE NINETY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA CELEBRATING WOMEN IN
PUBLIC OFFICE DAY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN
YOUR RECOGNIZE MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN YOUR ATTENTION
YOUR RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
ACR ONE NINETY FIVE WHICH WILL
PROCLAIM TODAY AS WOMEN IN
PUBLIC OFFICE DAY.
THE MONTH OF MARCH IS WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH WHERE WE HONOR
TRAILBLAZING WOMEN WHO CAME
BEFORE US AND THOSE WHO CONTINUE
TO PAVE THE WAY.
DURING THIS.
MONTH WE SHOULD TAKE A MOMENT TO
CELEBRATE ALL THE WOMEN WHO HOLD
PUBLIC OFFICE AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT WOMEN PROVIDE A
UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE IN POLICY AND
POLITICS. MAKING A BIG
DIFFERENCE AND HOW OUR
GOVERNMENT FUNCTIONS WHICH YOUR
NUMEROUS COMMITTEES CRAFT
INFLUENTIAL POLICY AND
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
BUILDING BIPARTISAN COALITIONS.
TO ADDRESS OUR SOCIETY'S MOST
PRESSING CONCERNS.
ALTHOUGH THE NUMBER OF WOMEN
SERVING IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE
HAS GROWN OVER THE LAST FIFTY
YEARS WOMEN REMAIN LARGELY UNDER
REPRESENTED.
LESS THEN A QUARTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE IS
COMPRISED OF WOMEN WHEN COMPARED
TO OTHER STATE LEGISLATURES THE
NATION CALIFORNIA IS RANKED
THIRTIETH IN FEMALE
REPRESENTATION.
CONSIDERING THAT NEARLY HALF OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE WOMEN THERE IS
PLENTY OF WORK STILL TO BE DONE.
THIS RESOLUTION WILL BRING
AWARENESS TO THE DISPARITY THAT
REMAINS AND HOPEFULLY INSPIRE
YOUNG WOMEN TO BECOME MORE
SPECIFICALLY INSPIRED.
PLEASE.
ENJOY A PLEASE JOIN ME AND
CELEBRATING ALL WOMEN WHO HOLD
PUBLIC OFFICE I AND I ASK FOR
THE FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LIMONIUM RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
ON BEHALF THE LATINO CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF ACR ONE NINETY FIVE
SELLING CELEBRATING WOMEN IN
PUBLIC OFFICE STATE. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF WOMEN.
THAT CONTRIBUTIONS WOMEN MAKE IN
THE POLICY ARENA. BECAUSE OF
WOMEN SHAPING PUBLIC POLICY WE
HAVE LAWS THAT RANGE FROM CHILD
CARE FOR WORKING WOMEN TO THE
ABILITY TO DIVORCE AND OWN
PROPERTY.
AND EVEN THE RIGHT TO WEAR
PANTS.
WE DO NOT HAVE REPRESENTED WE DO
NOT HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE
DEMOCRACY.
AS RECENTLY AS NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE ONLY TEN PERCENT OF
CONGRESS WAS FEMALE NOW. ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS LEADERS ONLY
EIGHTEEN PERCENT OF CONGRESS AND
TWENTY FOUR PERCENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE ARE
COMPRISED OF WOMEN.
I CURRENT RATES IT WILL TAKE A
HUNDRED IN SEVEN YEARS FOR WOMEN
TO COMPRISE FIFTY PERCENT OF
CONGRESS ACCORDING TO THE
INSTITUTE FOR WOMEN'S POLICY
RESEARCH.
WHY JANNAT RANKIN OF MONTANA WAS
THE FIRST WOMAN ELECTED TO THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES IN
NINETEEN SIXTEEN? IT WASN'T
UNTIL SEVENTY THREE YEARS LATER
THAT WE HAD OUR FIRST LATINA
ELECTED TO CONGRESS.
ILEANA ROS LEE IN THE FLORIDA
WON THE ELECTION TO THE HOUSE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE.
TODAY SHE IS STILL SERVING.
IN NINETEEN NINETY THREE LUCILLE
ROYBAL ALLARD FROM CALIFORNIA
WITH THE SECOND MEDINA EVER
ELECTED TO CONGRESS.
AND IT WASN'T UNTIL TWENTY
SIXTEEN THAT WE HAD LET THE NET
IN THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
LEADERSHIP. LINDA SANCHEZ OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE FIRST THAT THE US SENATOR
ASSUMED OFFICE IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. CATHARINE CORTES
MOSCOW FROM NEVADA.
CALIFORNIA HAS DONE A BIT BETTER
ELECTING GLORIA MOLINA TOWARDS
THE HOUSE IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO.
BUT THAT WAS SIXTY FOUR YEARS
AFTER THE FIRST WOMAN WAS
ELECTED IN NINETEEN EIGHTEEN.
SHAPING PUBLIC POLICY SHOULD BE
MADE BY MANY PERSPECTIVES MAKING
AN IMPORTANT TO ELEVATE WOMEN
AND WOMEN OF COLOR AND ENCOURAGE
THAT ENCOURAGING THEM TO SEEK
PUBLIC OFFICE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THE COMMANDER SPEAKER I RISE ON
BEHALF THE LGBT CAUCUS TO ALSO
WRITE THE SUPPORT OF ACR WHEN
NINETY FIVE. MEMBERS IS
IMPORTANT AS WE THINK ABOUT
WOMEN IN OFFICE THAT WE THINK
ABOUT WOMEN REPRESENTING ALL
PARTS OF THE DIVERSITY THAT IS
CALIFORNIA WHETHER WE BE MOTHERS
WHETHER WE BE LESBIANS WERE OUR
LATINAS OR. API'S ARE AFRICAN
AMERICANS IT REALLY IS THE VOICE
THAT WE BRING FORWARD
REPRESENTING WOMEN REPRESENTING
FAMILIES IN THE ISSUES THAT ARE
UNIQUE TO US SOMETIMES A THAT IT
IS IMPORTANT HAVE MORE ELECTED
WOMEN IN PUBLIC OFFICE. SO I HA
I STRONGLY SUPPORT ACR FIFTEEN
AT ONE NINETY FIVE AS WE
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARD TRUE
EQUALITY THAT MEANS TRUE EQUITY
THAT MEANS TRUE. EQUALITY IN
REPRESENTATION OF WOODEN WE VOTE
THINK ABOUT WOMEN. WHEN WE VOTE
THINK ABOUT WHO WHO IS GOING TO
BE THERE TO SPEAK FOR YOU NOT
THAT WE DON'T ALL SPEAK WITH ONE
UNANIMOUS VOICE. BUT THAT
DIVERSITY OF OUR VOICES IS WHAT
MAKES CALIFORNIA GRAY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON ACR WHEN NINETY FIVE.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
AGAIN ASK FOR YOUR I'VE. THANK
YOU WOULD YOU LIKE THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHOR YES.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS ROLES FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS RULES FOR CHO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON ACR ONE NINETY FIVE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
RULE THERE ARE SIXTY SIX CO
AUTHORS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ITEM SEVENTEEN PASS AND RETAIN.
MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTEEN SCR
NINETY SIX.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE YOU ARE
I'M NOT A CLERK WE PLEASED.
WE'VE PLEASE READ THE ITEM
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY SIX BY SENATOR DODD AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO EATING
DISORDERS AWARENESS WEEK.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM SPEAKER THIS
RESOLUTION RECOGNIZING
RECOGNIZES EATING DISORDERS
AWARENESS WEEK. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THIS YEAR THE THEME
IS LET'S GET REAL. FOCUSING ON
EXPANDING THE CONVERSATION
AROUND EATING DISORDERS TO
INCLUDE THE DIVERSE PERSPECTIVES
OF THE MILLIONS OF LIVES
AFFECTED. EATING DISORDERS ARE
OFTEN STIGMATIZE THERE ALSO
STEREOTYPED AND THIS YEAR THE
CAMPAIGN AIMS TO CORRECT
MISINFORMATION AND HELP PEOPLE
CONNECT WITH THE SUPPORT NEEDED
TO RECOVER. IN THE UNITED STATES
THIRTY MILLION PEOPLE SUFFER
FROM CLINICALLY SIGNIFICANT
EATING DISORDERS AT SOMETIME IN
THEIR LIVES EATING DISORDERS ARE
USUALLY. ASSOCIATE WITH SERIOUS
PSYCHOLOGICAL PROBLEMS SUCH AS
DEPRESSION SUBSTANCE ABUSE
SUICIDE EATING DISORDERS ARE A
FATAL MENTAL ILLNESS WITH THE
MORTALITY RATE BEING.
TWELVE TIMES HIGHER THAN THAT OF
OTHER MENTAL ILLNESSES.
EVEN DISORDERS ARE SERIOUS AND
ARE NOT A CHOICE IT IS IMPORTANT
TO RECOGNIZE THE SEVERITY OF
THESE CONDITIONS. AND DISPEL THE
HARMFUL STIGMA SURROUNDING THEM
EXPERTS HAVE FOUND THAT PROMPT
INTENSIVE TREATMENT
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVES THE
CHANCES OF RECOVERY. THIS IS WHY
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR EDUCATORS%
MEDICAL PROVIDERS PETE PARENTS
AND THE COMMUNITY TO BE AWARE OF
THE WARNING SIGNS AND SYMPTOMS.
RECOGNIZING NATIONAL EATING
DISORDERS AWARENESS WEEK WILL
HELP THE POPULATION UNDERSTAND
WENT TO OFFER HELP. AND WHERE TO
FIND IT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEEN A REQUEST TO
DISCUSS THE ITEM MISTER LEVINE
WOULD YOU LIKE COOPER IS ON THE
MEND.
PLEASE.
METAPHORICALLY IS OPEN THE ROLE
FOR COOPER MEMBERS.
THIS ROLE IS FOR COAL AUTHORS.
ON.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
HIS ROLES FOR COOPERS MEMBERS.
THAT A CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THEY'RE SIXTY FIVE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE ITEM ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
WERE GOING TO BE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A JOURNEY MEMORY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES TODAY ARE RISE TO
REQUEST THAT THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY. OF MY
FRIEND JOHN FRIEDERICH.
WHO PASSED AWAY UNEXPECTEDLY ON
OCTOBER ELEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY?
JOHN WAS A PALO ALTO BOY THROUGH
AND THROUGH. GRADUATING FROM
PALO ALTO HIGH SCHOOL BEFORE
GOING ACROSS THE STREET TO
ATTEND STANFORD UNIVERSITY AND
THEN STANFORD LAW SCHOOL.
WAS IT STANFORD WHERE HE WOULD
MEET JILL THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE
AND WIFE OF FIFTY FOUR YEARS.
JOHN WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A VERY
SICK JON WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
VERY SUCCESSFUL CAREERS.
FIRST AS A LAWYER ADVISING
STARTUP COMPANIES AND THEN AS A
LEADING SILICON VALLEY VENTURE
CAPITALIST AS THE FOUNDER OF BAY
PARTNERS. AND COFOUNDER OF REGIS
MANAGEMENT COMPANY.
JONES PROFESSIONAL SUCCESS GIVEN
THE FREEDOM TO FOCUS ON HIS
PASSION.
PHILANTHROPY.
ANY PARTICULAR HIS ALMA MATER
STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
OVER FORTY PLUS YEARS OF
LEADERSHIP AND GENEROSITY JOHN
WOULD SERVE AS CHAIR OF THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES OF THE
UNIVERSITY. AS WELL AS DIRECTOR
OF STANFORD UNIVERSITY HOSPITAL
AND LUCILLE PACKARD CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL.
AFTER THE NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
LOMA PRIETA EARTHQUAKE DAMAGE
THE CANTOR ARTS CENTER JOHN AND
JOE CONTRIBUTED MONEY TO REBUILD
THE CENTER AND THEN DOUBTS
DIRECTORSHIP.
IN ADDITION INSPIRED BY JULES
EXPERIENCES A BREAST CANCER
SURVIVOR.
JOHN AND JOE MADE A TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR DONATION TO
CREATE THE JONES ON FRIEDERICH
CENTER FOR TRANSLATIONAL
RESEARCH AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY
MEDICAL CENTER.
JOHN SERVED ON MANY OTHER BOARDS
AND SUPPORTED COUNTLESS OTHER
CAUSES
AND IS GENERAL GENEROSITY AND
SELF.
AND HIS GENEROSITY AND
SELFLESSNESS HASN'T WILL
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
COUNTLESS PEOPLE ACROSS THE LOOK
ON VALLEY IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT FOR ALL HIS LARGE SCALE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND SUCCESSES
JOHN WILL BE REMEMBERED MOST FOR
HIS KINDNESS AND HUMILITY.
JOHN AND I FIRST GOT TO KNOW
EACH OTHER OVER FIFTEEN YEARS
AGO WHEN I REACHED OUT TO SEE IF
YOU PUT IN A GOOD WORD FOR ME AT
STANFORD LAW SCHOOL.
WE TALKED FOR ABOUT HALF AN HOUR
COVERING EVERYTHING FROM PALO
ALTO TO NATIONAL POLITICS.
JOHN WAS A TITAN OF SILICON
VALLEY AND I WAS SOME MID
TWENTIES KID ASKING HIM FOR A
FAVOR. BUT DURING OUR
CONVERSATION IT TRULY FELT LIKE
HE WAS ENJOYING IT JUST AS MUCH
AS I WAS.
OVER THE YEARS I WOULD BECOME
THE BENEFICIARY OF MANY MORE
CHATS WITH JOHN.
HE WAS NEVER TOO BUSY FOR A
PHONE CALL OR TO GRAB LUNCH IN
DOWNTOWN PALO ALTO.
JOHN WAS ALWAYS HAPPY TO LISTEN
AND THEN OFFER HIS SAGE ADVICE.
HE WAS A MENTOR TO MANY
SUCCESSIVE LEADERS AND SILICON
VALLEY A MODEL OF KINDNESS
GENEROSITY AND RESPECT FOR ALL
OF US TO FOLLOW.
I REMEMBER ONE TIME WHEN I STOP
BY TO SAY HI AND JOHN WAS MAKING
HIS WAY AROUND THE OFFICE WITH
THE PITCHER OF WATER. WANDERING
EVERYONE'S PLANTS.
WHICH WAS HILARIOUS UNTIL HE
STARTED WATERING THE PLASTIC
ONES.
JOHN WAS ONE OF THE MOST
THOUGHTFUL GENUINE KIND PEOPLE I
KNOW.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE JILL
WHOSE CHILDREN GALA MARKS AND
ERIC FRIEDMAN RICH. AND THEIR
SPOUSES IN GERMANY.
HIS BROTHERS DAVID AND DENNIS
FRIEDERICH HIS SIX GRANDCHILDREN
JACQUELINE DANIELLE THEODORE
LUCILLE BEVERLY AND SYLVIA. AND
COUNTLESS FRIENDS AND ADMIRERS.
JON'S FRIENDS AND FAMILY ARE
GATHERED RIGHT NOW TO CELEBRATE
HIS LIFE ON STANFORD CAMPUS AND
WE'RE ALL GOING TO MISS HIM VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MEMBER I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF JOSE
BERNARDO. A LONG TIME STOCKTON
FILIPINO LEADER AND ACTIVISTS. A
DIED ON FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTH
ON AT HIS HOME.
I WAS BORN IN THE PHILIPPINES.
APRIL TWENTY FIRST NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT.
SERVED IN WORLD WAR TWO AND THEN
IMMIGRATED TO THE U. S.
CONTINUED AND SERVED IN KOREA
AND THE NAVY.
STARTED YOU WANT A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND CUT HIS ENGINEERING
DEGREE AND RAN J. BE ENGINEERING
FOR FOR YEARS AND YEARS.
HE WAS ONE OF THE FIRST LEADERS
AND STUCK IN THE FILIPINO
COMMUNITY WHO WHO WHO TOOK
INITIATIVE DURING. SOMEONE DOING
THEY'RE DOING ACROSS TOWN
FREEWAY ACROSS TOWN THAT WENT
RIGHT TO THE FILIPINO COMMUNITY
AND RIGHT THROUGH DOWNTOWN
CHINATOWN AND ALL OF OUR.
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THERE IN
AND TOOK A PLACE THAT HAD BEEN.
DEVASTATED BY THE ACROSS TOWN
FREEWAY AND WAS ABLE TO GET THE
FUNDING FOR THE FIRST.
LOW INCOME HOUSING FOR THE
FILIPINO COMMUNITY CALLED A
FILIPINO PLAZA. IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO WHERE HE SERVED ON
THAT BOARD UNTIL HE AT THE TIME
OF HIS DEATH THIS YEAR.
IT WAS SERVED ON THE.
STUCK IN SCHOOL BOARD HE WAS
ONE OF THE FIRST APPOINTEES BY
JERRY BROWN THE FIRST TIME
AROUND WHEN HE WAS TRYING TO
START TO LOOK FOR. THAT OUR
BOARDS AND COMMISSION SHOULD BE
LOOK AS DIVERSE AS CALIFORNIA HE
WAS APPOINTED TO THE NURSING
BOARD. AGAIN HE SERVED ON THE
STOCK AND UNIFIED SCHOOL BOARD A
HE WAS A PART OF LITTLE MANILA
HE WAS A PART OF THE LIONS CLUB
HE WAS A PART OF. A LOT OF GOOD
THINGS THAT OCCURRED IN THE
STOCKTON COMMUNITY.
HIS WAS PART OF STARTING THE
BARIO FAST THAT THEY HAD EVERY
YEAR THE FILIPINO PLAZA. A AND
HIS TO LOST LEAVES A HUGE HOLE
IN THE HEART OF STOCKTON LEAVES
BEHIND HIS WIFE. HE HAD THREE
SIBLINGS STILL ALIVE HE HAD A
SEVEN CHILDREN AND SIX
GRANDCHILDREN AND WE EXTEND THEM
OUR CONDOLENCES. AND JOIN THEM.
IN CELEBRATING THAT THE
INCREDIBLE LIFE OF JOSE
BERNARDO.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR CURRY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF DOCTOR JENNIFER GOLEC.
DOCTOR JENNIFER JENNIFER
GONZALEZ SHEESH REBA.
AND CRISTINA OVER.
THREE BRAVE WOMEN.
WHOSE LIVES WERE TRAGICALLY CUT
DOWN MUCH TOO SHORT LAST FRIDAY
AT THE PATHWAY HOUSE LOCATED ON
THE YACHT BILL VETERANS HOME
CAMPUS.
THE THREE WOMEN WERE STAFF
MEMBERS OF THE PATHWAY HOME A
NONPROFIT PROGRAM DESIGNED TO
HELP VETERANS WHO SUFFER FROM
PTSD.
ON THE MORNING OF MARCH NINTH
THE WOMEN ATTENDED A STAFF
PARTY.
WHEN AN ARMED GUARDSMAN AND
FORMER PATHWAY HOME RESIDENT
ENTERED THE ROOM.
TOOK THEM HOSTAGE BEFORE KILLING
THEM.
WE ARE PAINED BY THE SENSELESS
LOSS OF THESE THREE WOMEN.
WHO DEDICATED THEIR LIVES TO
HELPING VETERANS?
WE WISH TO HONOR THOSE WOMEN
TODAY.
DOCTOR JENNIFER GOLEC FORTY TWO
YEARS OLD CLINICAL DIRECTOR OF
THE PATHWAY HOME.
JENNIFER WAS A CALISTOGA NAPA
COUNTY NATIVE AND LIVED IN SAINT
ONLY KNOW WITH HER HUSBAND AN
EIGHT YEAR OLD DAUGHTER.
JENNIFER STUDIED AT UC DAVIS AND
EARNED HER MASTER'S DEGREE AT
CINEMA STATE UNIVERSITY.
AN AVERAGE SHARE OF SAN
FRANCISCO GIANTS FAN SHE LOVED
ATTENDING BASEBALL GAMES WITH
THEIR DAUGHTER.
CHOOSE A BELOVED MOTHER SISTER
DAUGHTER COLLEAGUE AND FRIEND
WHO WILL BE DEARLY MISSED.
DOCTOR JENNIFER GONZALEZ A SURE
SPREE BY. THIRTY TWO YEARS OLD.
CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGIST WITH THE
SAN FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS AND RESIDENT OF
NAPA.
SHE ATTENDED LOYOLA MARYMOUNT
LOS ANGELES AND EARNED HER
DOCTORAL DEGREE FROM PALO ALTO
UNIVERSITY.
JENNIFER WAS ADORED BY ALL WHO
KNEW HER.
SHE AND HER HUSBAND ARE GETTING
READY TO CELEBRATE THE FIRST
WEDDING ANNIVERSARY THIS MONTH.
THEY'RE ALSO EXPECTING THEIR
FIRST CHILD.
THE BABY DID NOT SURVIVE.
CHRISTINE LOW OVER FORTY YEARS
FORTY EIGHT YEARS OLD EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE PATHWAY HOME AND
RESIDENT OF NAPA.
CHRISTINE WAS BROUGHT ON AS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO HELP REBOOT
THE PATHWAY HOME PROGRAM. WHICH
WAS ON A SHORT HIATUS.
CHRISTINE GRADUATED FROM CUT
BOSTON COLLEGE OF SOCIAL WORK
EARNING HER DEGREE IN CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORK.
CRISTINA EMBRACE THE NAPA
COMMUNITY AND THE NAPA COMMUNITY
INTERNET EMBRACE CHRISTINE WITH
OPEN ARMS.
A POSITIVE ATTITUDE WAS
INFECTIOUS AND SHE ALWAYS HAD A
WONDERFUL SIGNATURE SMILE.
IT WAS IMPOSSIBLE TO WALK AWAY
FROM THE CONVERSATION WITH
CHRISTINE AND NOT FEEL ANYTHING
BUT JOY.
IN ADDITION TO WORKING A PATH
WHERE HOME PRISTINE TAUGHT YOGA
IN SANTA ROSA TO VETERANS OF
SUFFERING FROM PTSD.
THESE THREE WOMEN WERE PASSION
ABOUT THEIR WORK IN MISSION IN
LIFE.
THEY GOT UP EVERY MORNING WITH
ONE THING ON THEIR MIND.
HOW CAN I HELP VETERANS?
IT IS VERY SAD IT'S INCREDIBLY
SAD MY HEART WEEPS.
THE NAPA VALLEY IS VERY CLOSE
KNIT COMMUNITY.
THE COMMUNITY HAS SEEN ITS SHARE
OF DISASTERS FLOODS.
EARTHQUAKES AND FIRES.
BUT NOTHING HAS SHATTERED THE
NAPA VALLEY COMMUNITY TO ITS
CORE LIKE THIS HORRIFIC EVENTS
OF LAST FRIDAY.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT YOU JOIN MEAN ADJOURNING IN
THE MERRIER JENNIFER GOLEC.
DOCTOR JENNIFER GONZALEZ A SHISH
REBA.
CHRISTINE LOW OVER THREE BAY
BRAVE WOMEN.
MAY THEY REST IN PEACE.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
.
I RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY.
OF DOCTOR DETER COUP STIR.
WHO DIED ON SUNDAY MARCH FOURTH?
I FIRST MET THEATER OVER
FOURTEEN YEARS AGO AND ALONG
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM RANCHO
BERNARDO.
WE OFFER OUR SINCERE CONDOLENCES
TO URSULA HIS WIFE AND TO THEIR
FAMILY.
THEATER WAS WITH THE PHD IN
BIOCHEMISTRY WAS A LEADER IN
MOLECULAR SCIENCE.
AND HIS COMPANY CA BUT TANA
INTERNATIONAL WAS AN EARLY
ADOPTER OF THE USE OF PLANTS AND
FLOWERS FOR SKIN CARE AND THE
PREVENTION OF AGING.
ORIGINALLY FROM WESTFALEN
GERMANY DETER FACED MANY
HARDSHIPS GROWING UP INCLUDING
BEING SEPARATED FROM HIS MOTHER
AT TEN YEARS OF AGE WHEN HITLER
CAME INTO POWER.
WITHOUT HIS MOTHER TO GUIDE HIM.
DETER MADE HIS WAY ACROSS
GERMANY WITH TWELVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION OTHERS TO ESCAPE THE
ADVANCING RUSSIAN ARMY.
AT AGE TWENTY ONE THEATER WITH
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS IN
HIS POCKET IMMIGRATED FROM
GERMANY.
TO PURSUE HIS DREAM OF BECOMING
HIS OWN BOSS.
IN THE NINETEEN SIXTY TWO HE
STARTED OF HIS OWN PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS DISTRIBUTION.
HE THEN WENT ON TO ESTABLISH A
MANUFACTURING FACILITY IN SAN
DIEGO.
WHICH I WAS PRIVILEGED TO TOUR A
FEW YEARS AGO.
DETER CONDUCTED HIS OWN RESEARCH
IN BIOLOGY PLANT LIFE AND THE
WELL BEING OF YOUMANS. AND HE
PERSONALLY USED EVERY PRODUCT HE
MANUFACTURED IN FACT HE WAS
ALWAYS EXCITED TO SHOW US HIS
ARM WE GAVE IT PUT SOME OF THE
LOTIONS. AND.
EVEN THOUGH HE WAS IN HIS MID
EIGHTIES HE REALLY LOOKED LIKE
HE WAS SIXTY.
AND HE ALWAYS HAD THE MOST
INFECTIOUS AMAZING SMILE ON HIS
FACE AND IT JUST WAS SUCH A
SHOCK TO HEAR OF HIS DEATH.
DETERRED WAS RECENTLY QUOTED
SAYING HOW HE AND HIS WIFE
URSULA LOVE THE UNITED STATES.
AND FELT THEY ARE LIVING THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
DURING HIS MORE THAN FIFTY YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE IN THE COSMETIC
INDUSTRY HE AUTHORED MANY
ARTICLES WAS A SOUGHT AFTER
LECTURER. FOR THE INTERNATIONAL
BEAUTY INDUSTRY.
THEATER WAS A BELOVED MEMBER OF
THE COMMUNITY OF RANCHO SANTA FE
AND SAN DIEGO. AND HIS
ENTHUSIASTIC SMILE WILL BE
MISSED BY ALL.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IT'S
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I RISE
IN THE GERMAN MEMORY OF ALI YOU
SETTING.
SEXY BITTERSWEET THEIR WHERE
ADJOURNING TODAY BECAUSE ONE
YEAR AGO TODAY HE WAS IN THIS
CHAMBER UP IN THE GALLERY.
CELEBRATING THEIR IS WITH US.
HE WAS A BELOVED HUSBAND SON
BROTHER AND A FRIEND OF MINE WHO
PASSED AWAY ON MARCH TENTH AT
THE TENDER AGE.
THIRTY FIVE.
THOSE WHO KNEW HIM SAW HIM AS A
HUMBLE DEDICATED AND SMART
INDIVIDUAL WHO CARED SO MUCH
ABOUT HIS COMMUNITY.
WAS BORN AND RAISED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WENT TO THE EAST
COAST IT AT DARTMOUTH COLLEGE.
LIKE LADY BIRD HE HAD A PLACE IN
HIS HEART ONE TO COME BACK HOME.
HE CAME HOME WENT TO WORK WITH
HIS FATHER CYRUS YOU SETHI.
FOCUSED ON LOCAL INFILL
DEVELOPMENT AND HIGH QUALITY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
S. FATHER CYRUS IS THAT HE WAS
AN IMMIGRANT FROM IRAN.
YOU CAME TO SACRAMENTO TO MAKE
HIS COMMUNITY GREAT AND AND.
HIS FATHER JUST LIKE YOU STEFFI
CARED HIS FATHER JUST LIKE ALI
USE THAT HE CARED SO MUCH ABOUT
THE DIVERSITY OF SACRAMENTO WHEN
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY WAS
INCLUDED. IN OUR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND OUR DEVELOPMENT
THROUGHOUT OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
THIS IS A COMMUNITY THAT THRIVES
UPON PEOPLE LIKE HIM WHO STRIVE
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THEIR
HOME TOWNS AND DO SPEAK OUT
ABOUT ISSUES THAT ARE IMPORTANT
TO THEM. CARED ABOUT THE ARTS
COMMUNITY HE SPOKE ABOUT
SUPPORTING OUR REFUGEE
COMMUNITY.
AND. SOME OF HIS GREAT PROJECTS
YOU SEE AROUND THE COMMUNITY IN
SACRAMENTO. OVER ON OUR STREETS.
THEY ARE ST DEVELOPMENT THEY WAS
BUT THERE'S REDEVELOPMENT OUT
TEN YEARS AGO THAT WAS HIS
PROJECT
SEVEN HUNDRED K.. UNDER
CONSTRUCTION RIGHT NOW BEAUTIFUL
INFILL DEVELOPMENT PROJECT WHAT
WAS HIS.
WAS HIS UP PROJECT AS WELL.
LASTLY THE WAREHOUSE ARTIST
LOFTS OVER ON OUR STREET AS WELL
HE WORKED WITH HIS PARTNER. THEY
MARRY UP IN THE GALLERY TO MAKE
SURE THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOUSING.
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE
EVERYBODY INCLUDING OUR GREAT
ARTISTS IN THE COMMUNITY
SACRAMENTO. HE'LL BE GREATLY
MISSED BY MANY INCLUDING HIS.
HIS SPOUSE OZZIE HER PARTNERS IN
HIS PARENTS CYRUS.
AND THAT NOW YOU STEFFI PLEASE
JOIN ME IN OBSERVING IN HIS
MEMORY.
THANK YOU.
INTO RECESSED TO RECONVENE AT
THREE THIRTY PM FOR THE STATE OF
THE JUDICIARY ADDRESS.
I MEMBERS MS IRWIN ACID THE
MEMBERS OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
COME FORWARD. TO THE FRONT OF
THE CHAMBER FOR PHOTO TO MARK
CELEBRATING WOMEN PUBLIC SERVICE
DAY WHEN WE START THIS RECESS.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS TUESDAY MARCH TWENTIETH
CHECK IN SESSION. MARCH TO A
WEDNESDAY MARCH TWENTY FIRST
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY MARCH
TWENTY SECOND FLOOR SESSION AT
NINE AM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASS AND RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SING AND
HEARD HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS THIS HOUSE WILL STAND
IN RECESS AND WE'LL RECONVENE.
AT THREE THIRTY PM TODAY FOR THE
STATE OF THE JUDICIARY ADDRESS.
THE ASSEMBLY STANDS IN RECESS